monsieur le Président chers collègues la
commission des affaires économiques et
la commission des affaires européennes
sont réunies conjointement ce matin pour
auditionner Monsieur Thierry Breton
commissaire européen au Marché intérieur
Monsieur le Commissaire je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation il ne
fut pas facile de trouver une date
convenant à toutes les parties mais
l'essentiel y être et d'y être parvenu
nos deux commissions ont l'habitude de
vous additionner conjointement et
dernières auditions en présence ou en
visioconférence date du 2 juin 2020 et
du 11 janvier 2022 c'est donc la
première fois que nous ne vous entendons
sous la présente législature et je m'en
réjouis car vos prises de parole sont
toujours stimulantes votre champ de
compétence recouvre une large partie des
attributions qui sont impartis à la
commission des affaires économiques au
niveau national ainsi votre mission
consiste à mettre en place le cadre qui
permettra à l'Europe d'exploiter au
mieux la transition numérique qui a
garantir le bon fonctionnement du marché
unique dans le cas d'une concurrence
équitable notamment par l'établissement
d'une stratégie globale à long terme
pour l'avenir industriel de l'Europe et
d'une stratégie en faveur DPME vous avez
également des attributions dans le
domaine de l'espace je suis certain que
les questions des orateurs ce matin
permettront de balayer le large spectre
de vos missions y compris le domaine
spatial puisque la commission des
affaires économiques a créé récemment
une mission d'information sur l'avenir
de l'industrie spatiale européenne
personnellement je me concentrerai sur
les questions industrielles vous le
savez le gouvernement vient de déposer
auprès du Sénat un projet de loi relatif
à l'industrie verte dans les coordonné
les travaux préparatoires pardon et qui
sera soumis à notre assemblée mi-juillet
avez-vous pu prendre connaissance de ce
projet de loi d'une façon plus générale
comment agissez-vous pour que les
initiatives nationales des différents
États membres de l'Union européenne
renforcent l'Europe au lieu de la
diviser enfin pourriez-vous faire un
point sur votre action pour contrer les
concurrents plus décomplexés que nous je
pense évidemment à l'échine et aux
États-Unis leur inflation réduction
actes favorisant les entreprises clés
implantées sur leur territoire avant de
céder la parole au président Pierre
Alexandre glatch je rappelle le député
présent que nous ons ce matin les règles
en usage au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques un seul orateur de
groupe pour les deux commissions
disposant de 4 minutes au total en
incluant au moins une minute de temps de
réponse pour Monsieur breton qui
répondra donc directement après chacune
des interventions des orateurs et puis
ensuite une minute pour chaque question
qui seront prises en bloc et auxquelles
le commissaire pourra répondre plus
longuement monsieur le Président Anglade
c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président je me joins
évidemment au présent casse barrière
Monsieur le Commissaire pour vous
souhaiter la bienvenue aujourd'hui ici à
l'Assemblée nationale sommes très
heureux de pouvoir mener cette audition
qui est une audition importante et qui
intervient alors que notre stratégie
reconquête est de souveraineté
industrielle porte ses fruits en France
et en Europe l'inauguration cette
semaine d'une gigafactory Française de
batterie pour les véhicules électriques
en témoignent et aux côtés du Président
de la République le 11 mai dernier vous
aviez vous-même parlé de véritables
mutations de la doctrine européenne sur
l'industrie et la réindustrialisation
décarbonée est à l'oeuvre partout dans
nos territoires c'est une très bonne
chose je crois que la situation
politique l'exige alors que les rapports
de force économique entre puissance ne
cesse de s'exacerber aggravation des
tensions commerciales accélération de la
course aux matières premières critiques
mesure des loyales phoson la concurrence
sous prétexte de politique industrielle
chacun le voit désormais parmi les
Européens l'économie est un instrument
de souv et de puissance et l'Europe doit
y prendre toute sa place sans naïveté et
je crois que c'est l'action que que vous
menez avec la Commission en lien
évidemment avec le Parlement européen et
les parlements nationaux dans la
compétition stratégique mondiale les
chiots européens est bien le plus
pertinent pour consolider notre
souveraineté industrielle ceux qui sur
certains bancs fustigés en 2017
bien cette volonté de souveraineté
européenne en parlant d'une utopie
française voit bien que partout en
Europe le changement est en train de
s'opérer même chez nos amis allemands
avec le chancelier Scholl ce qui a
appelé dans son discours de Prague un
made in Europe en 2030 ce qui rejoint
très largement les positions françaises
qui ont été défendus je tiens aussi
Monsieur le Commissaire ce matin à salué
l'action qui a été la vôtre depuis 2019
en tant que commissaire chargé du marché
intérieur et de l'industrie vous avez
joué un rôle clé je crois qu'il faut le
redire pour protéger les Européens en
permettant la production d'ampleur de
vaccins contre le covid quand on se
rappelle la manière dont tout vous avez
démarré et dont tout ça a été reprise en
main ensuite notamment par la commission
je crois que il y a une action qui a été
décisive vous avez aussi permis une
régulation ambitieuse des services des
marchés numériques je pense en
particulier aux accords sur le DSA et le
DMA obtenu sous présence française
démontrant que l'Europe est aux
avant-postes pour mettre un terme au Far
West numérique je crois que c'est
intéressant aussi nous entendre sur
Twitter et les récentes et la conformité
qui va devoir être la sienne d'ici au
mois de septembre prochain je crois
il faut aussi se réjouir des progrès
réalisés plus largement sur tous ces
sujets mais avons encore beaucoup de
défis je pense en particulier au
renforcement de notre base industrielle
et technologique de défense c'est
exigence est au cœur de la solidarité
européenne avec l'Ukraine qui défend nos
valeurs contre l'agression russe nous
pouvons là aussi nous féliciter de la
réaction de la réactivité européenne qui
a rapidement présenté des mesures
concrètes pour bâtir une économie de
guerre et accélérer la livraison
l'acquisition conjoint de munition c'est
le sens de la proposition de règlement
ASAP 500 millions d'euros pour fournir
davantage de munitions à la résistance
ukrainienne et cela dès que possible
nous comptons sur les États membres et
sur le Parlement européen pour parvenir
à un accord le plus rapidement possible
voilà Monsieur le Commissaire il y
aurait bien d'autres sujets sur l'IRA
sur notre réponse commune mais je laisse
évidemment loisir au commissaire de vous
interroger sur ce sujet et donc cette à
vous d'avoir la parole désormais merci
encore pour votre présence
et bien
pour la vidéo c'est mieux que vous
preniez
beaucoup Monsieur les présidents
chers Guillaume kasbien Richard
Pierre-Alexandre Anglade de me permettre
aujourd'hui de m'exprimer devant vous
tous et vous tous mesdames et messieurs
les députés pour parler précisément d'un
sujet
qui vraiment m'est cher et qui est
extrêmement important pour pour nous
Européens et pour nous Français qui est
la souveraineté industrielle vous l'avez
rappelé l'un et l'autre monsieur les
présidents
je crois vraiment qu'on peut dire que ce
thème là vous l'avez dit du reste ne
fait plus débat il est maintenant ancré
et il fait partie je l'espère en tout
cas je me suis beaucoup battu pour ça
évidemment au niveau de la Commission
européenne au niveau de l'Europe elle
fait partie de notre ADN et j'espère
pour pour longtemps
d'abord
on peut dire que qu'est-ce qui nous a
fait évoluer évidemment c'est la suite
il faut bien lire les choses comme elles
sont des crises permanentes on peut dire
que nous avons vécu au cours des trois
quatre dernières années et d'abord les
crises disons très ponctuelles comme la
crise sanitaire vous avez fait référence
la crise énergétique
il y a évidemment les conséquences de
cette agression terrible voulue par la
lumière Poutine en Ukraine et la guerre
donc qu'il mène sur le territoire
européen il y a évidemment les crises
systémiques la crise climatique et au
fond dans tout ça il faut que
on trouve des réponses et on le sait et
je crois qu'on a appris quelque chose au
cours de ces dernières années il y a pas
un seul pays un seul pays qui peut
lutter contre ces crises c'est parce que
nous sommes ensemble que nous
représentons 450 millions de concitoyens
européens parce que nous sommes au fond
le premier marché au monde que nous
pouvons trouver des solutions face à
l'ampleur de cette crise du reste on l'a
bien vu ceux qui ont voulu s'extraire
de notre union en souffre c'est une
évidence je ne désigne une personne mais
vous l'avez compris à qui je pensais et
là c'est ceux qui nous ont quitté en
tout cas pour quitter notre union donc
au fond
tout ça nous a incité à aller plus vite
et à réfléchir à travailler ensemble à
travers à travers finalement une seule
une réflexion et je voudrais
m'y arrêter
il suffit plus d'être une puissance ou
une seule puissance en matière de
recherche bien sûr la recherche est
extrêmement importante l'innovation
aussi mais il faut aussi avoir une
capacité de production domestique une
capacité de production industrielle sur
notre continent européen et bien entendu
dans nos États membres en particulier la
France et ça c'est vraiment un
changement de paradigme que je porte dès
le premier jour de ma venue à la
Commission
et qui évidemment trouve un relais vous
l'avez dit le prénom de la République la
portée très fort
la portée d'abord en France il a porté
aussi lorsqu'il assumait la présidence
de l'Union européenne ce terme de
souveraineté industrielle c'est pour moi
un agenda transversal qui se retrouve
sur tous les terrains
d'abord dans la réalité évidemment de
nos usines comme dans le monde numérique
l'usine sont aussi de plus en plus
interconnectés avec le monde numérique
sur la terre comme dans le ciel et dans
l'espace dans le civil comme dans le
militaire
et donc ça suppose une réponse très
claire non ambiguë
et que je porte
bien sûr avec d'autres
c'est la fin de l'Europe naïve
et au contraire j'ai pas peur de le dire
l'affirmation d'une Europe puissance qui
prend en fait en main son destin
industriel qui va nous permettre
d'exporter nos technologies et nos
produits plutôt que nos emplois
je dis sans détour pour moi il y a pas
de fatalité
il faut voir les choses en opportunité
on y travaille évidemment de façon
européenne depuis maintenant que je suis
commissaire c'est-à-dire en s'appuyant
sur nos forces et donc il faut toujours
essayer de voir qu'elles sont nos forces
dans un enjeu comme celui-ci bien sûr on
a des faiblesses mais si on s'attache
canaux faiblesses
et bien on avance peut-être pas la
vitesse qu'il faut à laquelle il faut
avancer ou sur nos forces pour pouvoir
combler ensuite nos faiblesses d'abord
la première force c'est comme ça que je
voudrais structurer mon intervention si
vous le permettez c'est le marché
intérieur c'est le marché intérieur
évidemment par rapport à ce qu'il offre
en termes d'emploi en termes de
créativité dans son unicité mais c'est
aussi le marché intérieur en termes
d'instruments géopolitique
deuxièmement c'est notre capacité à
transformer notre leadership
technologique en leadership industriel
et commercial j'ai bien dit industriel
et puis troisièmement c'est la richesse
de notre capital humain existant bien
sûr mais à continuer à développer et
adapter dans ce nouveau triptique alors
d'abord sur le marché intérieur en tant
que instrument géopolitique
je dis le continuum des crises auquel
nous faisons face en fait ça traduit un
changement
fondamental dans ce qu'on appelait la
mondialisation
et en fait j'essaie de le résumer en
disant qu'on est passé d'une période la
mondialisation était le maître mot à une
nouvelle ère que moi je qualifie d'air
de géopolitique des chaînes de valeurs
quand on parle évidemment de
l'infrastructure industrielle il y a
évidemment l'instrument l'usine le lieu
mais il y a évidemment en amont ne sait
à l'ombre très important de chaînes de
valeur nationale
intracommunautaire et international et
puis évidemment en aval tout ce qui
concerne évidemment la fabrication la
fabrication assistée le time to market
les produits qui sont de plus en plus
finalisés pour avoir des besoins
spécifiques par rapport aux usages donc
en avalent également et c'est vraiment
comme ça que on a progressivement essayé
de reconstruire notre marché intérieur
je le disais tout à l'heure il est une
fois une demi plus important que le
marché américain je rappelle j'ai encore
un plaisir j'étais au nord de la Suède
j'avais une conférence bien annuelle
avec
nos homologues américains il y avait le
secrétaire d'établinken la secrétaire
commerce raymondo et la secrétaire au
commerce taille et j'aurais rappelé
évidemment qu'on est une fois et demi
plus gros évidemment notamment en
numérique que le marché américain c'est
donc normal que on défendent ce que nous
sommes
et c'est comme si comme ça en s'appuyant
sur ses forces que nous avons bâti vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure et bien
les infrastructures réglementaires au
niveau communautaire c'est à dire au
niveau de l'ensemble du marché européen
pour avoir enfin un marché européen
numérique un marché numérique grâce à
des régulations transverses
identique pour tous les pays ce sont des
règlements que nous avons mis en place
et qui ont été voté par nos instances
démocratiques européennes c'est à dire
le Parlement européen que certains
connaissent bien ici et le Conseil
européen sont donc nos deux
collégicateurs je parle évidemment du
DSA et du DMA qui sont une architecture
donc qui permettent désormais d'avoir
les mêmes règles partout qui vont
s'appliquer partout en Europe sur les
plateformes pour donner enfin des règles
au niveau sociétal le DSA est aussi au
niveau économique avec le DMA dans cet
espace numérique qui était voulu dit
tout à l'heure bien un peu une sorte de
Far West parce qu'il y avait pas de
règle qui les structuré
et c'est vrai que désormais entre
l'Europe parle voilà les plateformes les
grandes plateformes doivent écouter
évidemment doivent s'adapter à nos
régulations et plus l'inverse c'est vrai
que c'était un peu on avait le sentiment
que c'était un peu l'inverse je le dis
là aussi comme dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines nous sommes un continent qui
est évidemment ouvert aux autres mais
désormais nous avons des conditions et
si on respecte ces conditions on est les
bienvenus et si on les respecte pas on
peut pas opérer sur le marché intérieur
c'est des avrées pour nombre de produits
moins en tant que commissaire en marché
intérieur j'ai des équipes qui vont
surveiller que lorsque on importe des
produits de l'extérieur par exemple des
jouets il faut il y a des spécifications
par exemple des produits qui commencent
et qui peuvent contenir des des intrants
toxiques tout ça est réglementé et donc
on peut pas
importer n'importe quoi sur le marché
intérieur il y a des règles et bien
c'est vrai désormais aussi sur dans
l'espace numérique j'aurai l'occasion
évidemment de d'en parler avec vous
c'est vrai aussi cette force vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure implicitement
lorsque vous l'avez dit au début de la
crise du covid chaque pays c'est fermé
sur lui-même chacun a essayé de voir
comment ils pouvaient faire
et puis on s'est dit finalement
l'ampleur de l'enjeu est tel qu'il faut
qu'on se mette ensemble et on s'est mis
ensemble pour acheter pour développer la
recherche sans l'avait fait auparavant
beaucoup des vaccins qui ont été
utilisés étaient des vaccins qui avaient
été financé par l'Europe la plupart du
réseau d'entre eux en particulier avec
les vaccins RN messagers et on s'est mis
ensemble et on s'y met ensemble d'abord
pour acheter mais aussi c'était la tâche
qui m'a été confiée pour faire monter
très rapidement la capacité de
production industrielle et
pharmaceutique en usine à des nouveaux
usines en Europe
on pensait que c'était une émission
impossible en l'espace de moins d'un an
l'Europe est devenue sur ses vaccins la
pharmacie Du Monde on a été le premier
exportateur d'abord pour nous
livrons pour nos propres concitoyens
mais la moitié aussi exportée dans le
monde on est passé d'une capacité de 20
millions de doses de fabrication par
mois à 300 millions en l'espace de
quelques mois c'est un exploit
industriel et qui nous a montré que là
encore je peux vous le dire parce
qu'avec mes équipes c'est ce qu'on a
fait c'est en travaillant ensemble en
mutualisant les chaînes de valeur en
travaillant sur les goulets
d'étranglement que nous avons pu
progressivement monter notre capacité
globale pharmaceutique c'était encore le
marché intérieur qui va finalement bon
normalement a réussi à maintenir notre
approvisionnement en énergie l'hiver
dernier
et qui nous a permis alors que tout le
monde disait que c'était impossible dès
que la guerre a démarré à débuter en
février donc en Ukraine dernier on sait
que
beaucoup on a vu que Vladimir Poutine
utilisait beaucoup des dépendances qui
existaient entre l'Union européenne et
la Russie comme des armes hybrides
et en particulier celle de l'énergie
volontairement on a voulu on a pensé
qu'il était indispensable de se
découpler de cette dépendance et
notamment en matière de gaz
beaucoup disaient que c'était impossible
en l'espace de 8 mois on a réussi à le
faire avec évidemment d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement du gaz naturel qui
est fier en particulier mais pas que et
aujourd'hui le prix du gaz est moins
élevé que il était avant le début des
hostilités en Ukraine donc on a réussi à
faire ça plateforme commune je vous
assure voilà contribué à le faire
notamment avec ma collègue et résistance
qui me semble c'est pas quelque chose
qui s'est fait tout seul mais une
coordination une très forte coordination
européenne pour pouvoir le faire et
c'est aussi ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui
en train de faire en mettant en commun
nos capacités de industriels de défense
pour pouvoir augmenter nos capacités de
production notamment d'armement et de
munitions on en a besoin pour nous nos
États membres ont beaucoup donné de ces
armements et munitions à l'Ukraine pour
faire face évidemment à l'agression et
pour répondre à la demande des autorités
de défense tous les États membres donc
ils ont réduit leur stock évidemment il
s'agit de remonter très rapidement les
stocks parce qu'il faut les stocks au
niveau nécessaire y compris au niveau
nécessaire à des guerres de haute
intensité il faut aussi pouvoir
continuer à livrer ce dont
l'Ukraine a besoin et on a pris
l'engagement de fournir un million de
munitions à l'horizon 12 mois mais
surtout de monter notre capacité
industrielle donc en matière de défense
et d'industrie de défense pour pouvoir
produire un million de ses munitions à
peu près par an ce qui nous semble être
nécessaire dans le monde géopolitique
dans lequel nous vivons pour les années
à venir et c'est un effort évidemment
donc que je mène puisque je suis
responsable aussi des industries de
défense donc en ayant donc visité à plus
de 15 pays donc l'État membre qui
disposent de ses capacités industrielles
les mettre enfin ensemble travailler
enfin ensemble réfléchir enfin aux
chaînes de valeur au chaîne
d'approvisionnement pour pouvoir faire
face à cette à cet enjeu je lisais tout
à l'heure les questions géopolitiques
elles nous aussi au-dessus de nos têtes
et en particulier à l'heure où l'espace
est un domaine de plus en plus contesté
disputés il est aussi absolument
essentiel que l'Europe tienne son rang
de très grandes puissances spatiale
alors on a déjà deux constellations
souveraines que vous connaissez bien la
constellation Galileo qui permet d'avoir
notre positionnement par satellite c'est
extrêmement utile elle est la plus
performante du monde les plus
performantes que le GPS américains elle
permet de d'avoir tous les
positionnements que nous utilisons
quotidiennement par exemple dans nos
voitures dans nos véhicules dans nos
smartphones enfin tout ça donc
fonctionne évidemment grâce à Galileo ça
aussi des applications dans le domaine
gouvernemental et de défense bien
entendu et puis il y a de la
constellation aussi Copernicus qui a le
fournit des images en temps réel de la
planète pour toutes les applications en
particulier les applications climatiques
mais pas que
aujourd'hui avoir une connaissance de ce
qui se passe en temps réel sur la
planète au niveau spatial est évidemment
extrêmement important
mais comme vous le savez on a également
lancé une troisième constellation qui
était très importante que notre
constellation iris donc qui elle va
fournir de la connectivité au niveau
européen connectivité
ultra sécurisée d'abord pour les
communications intergouvernementales
pour aussi passer dans l'air
post quantique on appelle ça comme ça
c'est à dire à partir du moment où on va
avoir des capacités quantiques notamment
de calculateur quantique d'ordinateur
quantique qui vont se développer on sait
qu'un symptôme des codes qui protège
aujourd'hui les réseaux classiques de
communication en particulier Internet
pourront être cassés je m'en sens
particulier au code RSA et donc il
fallait aussi avoir une capacité d'avoir
de la cryptologie quantique dans ces
communications pour des applications
spécifiques en particulier
gouvernementale ou de défense mais pas
que donc c'est toutes ces applications
que va porter la constellation Iris qui
va voir le jour donc ça y est les appels
d'offres sont en cours l'assiette est
votée également par les collégicateurs
c'est un très important projet européen
de souveraineté qui couvre évidemment
aussi les besoins
commerciaux j'allais dire
privé pour nos particuliers ceux qui
n'ont pas accès à
au débit dans certaines parties de
l'Union européenne la constellation est
une constellation Nord-Sud orbite basse
elle va s'appuyer aussi sur des
constellations en orbite moyenne et en
géostationnelle qui existe déjà donc
c'est une réconciliation qui sera les
plus évolué beaucoup plus sophistiquée
que celle qui existe aujourd'hui par
rapport aux besoins qui sont les nôtres
mais couvrira aussi l'Afrique car nous
voulons offrir aussi à l'Afrique la
capacité d'avoir de la connectivité sur
l'ensemble du continent africain alors
évidemment afin d'utiliser tout ce
marché intérieur que je viens de décrire
à grands pas comme outil géopolitique il
faut aussi nous douter d'outils
permettant des rapports de force car en
fait quand je dis c'est la fin de
l'Europe naïve il faut savoir aussi si
c'est nécessaire utiliser des rapports
de force dans les relations que nous
pouvons entretenir avec d'autres
continent je rappelle je me donne un
exemple lorsque je m'occupais j'étais en
charge des vaccins qu'elle n'a pas été
ma surprise de très rapidement lorsqu'on
m'a confié cette mission de découvrir
qu'une partie importante des
usines qui fabriquaient les composants
nécessaires notamment à la RN messager
vous pensez aux lipides on peut penser à
un certain nombre de sacs spécialisés
etc et était fabriqué dans nos usines
européennes qui étaient aux Etats-Unis
mais c'était des usines européennes et
il se trouve que le gouvernement
américain avait mis ce qu'on appelle
dans son jargon un DPA c'est-à-dire une
interdiction d'export des vaccins mais
aussi des composants constituants ces
vaccins
pour toute entreprise qui était le
qualité localisée aux États-Unis tant
que on n'aurait pas atteint l'immunité
collective aux États-Unis mes
usines elles étaient de l'autre côté et
je bloqué le développement donc j'avais
un interlocuteur qui était
on appelle ça dans le jargon c'était les
US shifts
et moi j'étais le Iuchi Maxime tasforce
quoi donc on se voit on se parlait tous
les mots toutes les semaines et nos
équipes je lui dis écoute
c'est bien mais tu vois là j'ai de mes
usines mais tu me bloques elle me dit
oui mais j'ai une interdiction de
l'export
ah bah oui mais c'est comme ça donc je
suis revenu à la Commission on a une
grande discussion au collège on a passé
un acte de législatif de réciprocité en
urgence qui a été voté aussi par nos
collégisateurs très rapidement en disant
que si un pays d'exercer ce type de
démarche on pouvait appliquer la
réciprocité quelques semaines plus tard
il y avait des composants qui étaient
fabriqués pour une entreprise au
Pays-Bas qui était très important j'ai
donc dit mon interlocuteur écoute tu
vois la cela tu le veux mais il semble
bloqués il me commence à bloquer c'est
du chantage bah oui mais c'est ce que tu
me fais donc tu me bloques je te
débloque et on a débloqué on est devenu
mon ami et les chaînes de valeur ont pu
se réouvrir je vais aussi cette anecdote
qui est une réalité pour vous dire
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que la
géopolitique des chaînes de valeurs
évidemment pour pouvoir le faire il faut
avoir on le fait pas sur nos faiblesses
on le fait sur nos points forts c'est
pour ça que je nous force à essayer de
bien identifier quelles sont ses points
forts parce que c'est sur ces piliers là
qu'on peut bâtir ensuite des relations
équilibrées y compris avec ceux qui
peuvent être nos meilleurs partenaires
parce que le monde est ce qu'il est et
que l'Europe ne peut plus être naïve
c'est ça utiliser le marché intérieur
comme nouvelle je dirais moyen
géo-politique de manière plus large il
faut aussi
avoir des éléments de défense
commerciale aussi et notamment de bien
pouvoir voir qu'en particulier quand il
y a des investissements ils se font sur
des critères ou des normes qui sont
identiques aux autres et donc on a
maintenant ces instruments on appelle ça
notre jargon les FDIS training c'est à
dire des aliments qui vont pouvoir faire
du suivi de tout ce qui est
investissement en amont des entreprises
qui vont pouvoir soit investir soit
fabriquer leurs produits de façon à ce
que le règlement sur les subventions
étrangères puissent veiller à ce que les
subventions des pays tiers ne fausse pas
la concurrence sur le marché unique
encore une fois je le dis c'est pour
nous on est contre personne
mais on sait quelle est notre force on
dit à tous ceux qui veulent venir chez
nous vous étiez bienvenus mais voilà nos
règles et mon travail à moi le
commissaire européen marché intérieur
c'est de veiller à ce que ces règles
soient efficaces qu'elle soit appliquée
et qu'elle soit comprise aussi par ceux
qui vont vouloir venir bénéficier de
notre marché intérieur et on les
accueille vous voyez il se trouve que en
Europe continental en tout cas on roule
à droite
si quelqu'un vient me dire oui moi c'est
dommage j'ai des voitures qui roulent à
gauche et bah c'est dommage nous on
roule à droite voilà donc il faudra se
mettre le volant à gauche parce que dans
nos voitures le volant il est à gauche
et voilà il faut que j'explique ça c'est
mon travail de commissaire pour marcher
intérieur dans tous les domaines voilà
donc et c'est ça quand on dit au fond
ouvert l'Europe est ouverte mais à nos
conditions et je vais vous dire ça a
l'air simple cette petite phrase
ça m'a valu des heures et des semaines
de négociation y compris au sein de la
commission parce que quand je suis
arrivé je le dis de façon très libre
c'était
du temps où Monsieur bon pas arrêté
d'encore là l'Europe est ouverte
voilà on me dit nous on est ouvert
c'était notre fierté
et moi pendant les deux premières années
je me suis allé à dire oui mais ouvert
mais à nos conditions et on a eu un
débat au sein du collège il y avait
effectivement il y a eu certains qui
défendaient cette posture et finalement
c'est cette posture qui l'a emporté et
c'est celle qui que l'on décline et qui
nous permet de définir maintenant ce que
c'est que la souveraineté industrielle
alors le deuxième point c'est comment
transformer le leadership technologique
en leadership industrielle il y a un
moment où certains disaient
l'industrie sans vous souvenez les
entreprises sans usine bon c'était une
caricature
ça fait du mal il n'y a pas encore une
fois je dis d'entreprises industrielle
sans usine d'abord parce que
la fabrication même les usines le fait
de fabriquer des produits c'est de plus
en plus des produits qui attaquent de la
valeur ajoutée qui intègre en
particulier des composants des
composants électroniques des pays
conducteurs qui eux-mêmes vont intégrer
des applications spécifiques qui sont
développées pratiquement en même temps
avec les utilisateurs et donc en
proximité la notion de proximité d'un
outil industriel désormais par rapport à
son marché est extrêmement important moi
c'est quelque chose auquel je crois
profondément donc il y a d'abord déjà
cette évolution on parle de l'industrie
4.0 etc ces industries qui nécessitent
de plus en plus de compétences
numériques sont de plus en plus intégrés
directement aussi avec leurs clients et
les clients ils interviennent quasiment
en aval vous souvenez quand on a acheté
une voiture il y a 20 ans on était très
très contents parce que quand on allait
chez le concessionnaire il vous disait
et maintenant la voilà vous pouvez
choisir la couleur
la couleur des fauteuils la couleur de
la voiture si vous voulez un autoradio
ou pas si vous voulez et on avait
l'impression que oui on participait en à
la conception du véhicule mais ça c'est
vrai maintenant dans tous les produits
le client il intervient quasiment en
amont à la fabrication donc il faut être
en proximité de l'outil industriel et en
particulier dans les interactions
numériques qui sont de plus en plus
importantes que ce que les applications
numériques de base ou des applications à
base d'intelligence artificielle on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler on en parle
beaucoup ces temps-ci tout ce qui
interagit de façon numérique avec son
environnement qui enrichit le produit
des services qu'il va porter évidemment
nécessite cette proximité y compris en
fabrication y compris en proximité des
chantres de recherche y compris aussi en
formation des jeunes qui vont devoir
donc se former à cette sorte dualité à
la fois industrielle mais aussi tout ce
qui concerne la commercialisation et la
recherche et donc le marketing et la
recherche donc en amont donc c'est un
point pour nous qui est très important
et il a fondé du reste un autre combat
que j'ai mené assez vite qui a été un
peu
compliqué qui était de dire il faut
qu'on commence par réimpatrier des
usines deux composants et de
semi-conducteurs en Europe on a laissé
filer au cours des 30 40 dernières
années un nombre important de nos usines
de semis conducteurs on sait elles ont
filé on sait où elles ont filé
essentiellement à Taïwan en Asie du
Sud-Est et au fond on était là
uniquement des ambassiettes qui va être
le plus compétitif donc parce que
c'était c'était le coup du travail il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont
qui est incitées ce type de démarche et
puis et puis on voit maintenant
l'importance des semis conducteurs il y
a pour vous donner un chiffre qui a en
2000 à peu près il y a il y avait on
fabriquait en gros 40% de la production
mondiale en Europe aujourd'hui on est à
10% les États-Unis c'était pareil et
aujourd'hui ils sont aussi à 10%. parce
qu'on a fait la même chose que les
États-Unis et donc on s'est dit en
regardant un peu les projections ben on
va on va essayer maintenant de faire en
sorte contenu de l'évolution mondiale
évidemment on est qu'on a un grand
continent mais l'Europe c'est 440
millions d'habitants sur une planète de
9 milliards d'habitants je ne cesse de
le rappeler ça remet un peu les choses à
là doivent être remises il faut toujours
avoir ça en
il n'en demeure pas moins que si on
produit 20% des semis conducteurs en
Europe à l'horizon 2030 c'est notre
objectif on sera vraiment dans une
solution dans une situation solide pour
garantir le bon fonctionnement de nos
chaînes de valeur mais aussi pour
fournir à nos usines ce dont elles ont
besoin et ce dont je parle aujourd'hui y
compris nos usines industrielles qui
toutes vont intégrer peu ou ce type de
semi-conducteur que ce soit
à je dirais classique ou à plus forte
valeur ajoutée et moi je souhaite qu'on
soit évidemment le plus avancé possible
avec la production de Smic conducteurs
donc qui vont pardon des chiffres merci
en dessous de 10 nanomètres c'est à dire
de 10 milliards de mètres voire les plus
avancés en dessous de deux nanomètres
parce que c'est là où on a les plus
grandes puissances de calcul qui vont
être nécessaires au produit de demain
donc on a fait cette
[Musique]
on appelle ça le
type Act européen ship Act en anglais
qui nous donne un cadre d'investissement
et qui nous permet aujourd'hui d'ouvrir
clairement d'accueillir un nombre très
important de
d'industrie et d'usine dans ces domaines
pour pouvoir répondre à ses besoins
on a fait aussi beaucoup de choses en
matière de alors cette fois-ci de ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon de la clean
tech c'est-à-dire la technologie propre
tout ce qui constitue au fond cette
transition on a une double transition
massive évidemment aujourd'hui en Europe
la transition numérique j'en ai parlé
elle a besoin de ce myconducteur c'est
l'architecture qui va la rendre possible
qui va rendre ensuite tous les
applicatifs possibles il y a je dirais
sont son jumeau je peux dire en tout cas
industriel c'est la transition verte qui
a besoin de plus en plus de composants
critiques mais aussi d'infrastructures
et aussi d'usine pour fabriquer
effectivement et bien tout ce qui va
contribuer au verdissement et la
décarbonation de nos économie là aussi
on a laissé filer beaucoup beaucoup de
choses en Chine on sait qu'il y a
quelques années on était les leaders en
fabrication de panneaux photovoltaïques
aujourd'hui c'est la Chine qui est qui
le fait à 98% donc il s'agit de
reconquérir tout simplement ces marchés
pour les raisons que j'ai indiquées et
c'est ce qu'on a fait avec le on appelle
ça dans nous avons le net 0 industrie
Act c'est-à-dire c'est vrai que c'est un
peu un pendant de ce qui a été fait par
là américain une question de réduction
acte américain on pourra dire parler
tout à l'heure j'en ai encore parlé
longuement hier avec avec
le scooter blinken sur la réponse
européenne à quelque chose que j'étais
le premier dénoncé vous vous en souvenez
dès le mois de septembre l'année
dernière on a maintenant notre réponse
elle me semble adaptée et équilibrée il
fallait la mettre très rapidement en
place pour éviter évidemment qu'il y ait
quelques sortes une force d'attractivité
et d'appel très forte de nos industries
car au fond cette course à la
réindustrialisation
elle n'a pas lieu qu'en Europe elle a
lieu aussi comme je vous le disais tout
à l'heure dans d'autres pays et en
particulier aux États-Unis mais aussi en
Chine donc il faut là aussi savoir se
donner les moyens y compris financiers y
compris réglementaires accélérer la
notion de permis dans beaucoup de cartes
il me faut trois ans pour avoir une
autorisation pour faire une usine
d'hydrolyseur pour faire de l'hyd
l'électrolyseur il me faut 4 ans pour
faire voilà il faut donc on accélère
tout en gardant évidemment tout ce qui
est important pour nous c'est à dire la
préservation des relations à
l'environnement la biodiversité mais il
faut accélérer les autorisations de
permis de ces sites industriels en
respectant évidemment nos normes
alors on a on s'est fixé là aussi des
objectifs importants en particulier sur
les industries vertes donc on on
souhaite que 40% et donc on se donne les
moyens y compris financiers au niveau
européen et bien sûr français on a vu
c'est des annonces en particulier vous
les idées référence tout à l'heure à pas
plus tard qu'hier donc dans les
batteries qui se font partie évidemment
des composants essentiels de ce domaine
40% de besoins en termes de déploiement
pour la clintech donc à l'horizon 2030
10 à 40% selon les différents types de
chaînes de valeur parce que là aussi
évidemment dans tous ces industries que
ce soit les SMIC conducteurs mais aussi
tout ce qui compte aussi désormais ce
qu'on appelle la clindex c'est-à-dire
tout ce qui contribue à fabrication
d'énergie renouvelable les éoliennes les
panneaux photovoltaïques les pompes à
chaleur mais aussi et je me suis
beaucoup battu pour ça pour que le
nucléaire en fasse partie et le
nucléaire fait partie je le dis de façon
très claire je dis dès le premier jour
sans aucune idéologie sans nucléaire il
est impossible d'atteindre l'objectif de
décarbonation en 2050 il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui on a à peu près 25 à 30%
de notre production d'électricité qui
est nucléaire à l'horizon 2050 il faudra
qu'elle soit encore à 20% minimum tout
en doublant la capacité de production
électrique vous voyez donc il faut
augmenter au contraire nos capacités
nucléaires si on le fait pas on y
arrivera pas c'est l'énergie des
carbonées là il s'agit aussi de
continuer à investir et là vous voyez il
y a aussi un point qui est très
important pour moi je suis ingénieur je
sais très bien que il faut donner aussi
aux jeunes l'envie d'aller travailler
dans des filières on a un peu découragé
peut-être par le passé vous avez eu des
commissions qui vous l'ont dit par le
passé le fait de vouloir attirer des
jeunes talents dans le domaine du
nucléaire y compris du nucléaire propre
évidemment il faut leur redonner la
visibilité je suis de ceux qui croient
aussi à au générateur de 4e génération
propre il faut continuer à investir dans
la fusion nucléaire il faut continuer il
faut continuer à faire avoir ses
investissements parce qu'on sait que
c'est une partie importante et propre
totalement de notre avenir donc c'est
tout ça qu'on couvre évidemment par dans
ce dans cet aspect donc du soutien et du
et du financement donc de notre
industrie qui vont être le sous-jacent à
la transition et puis je vois que les
deux présidents me disent qu'il faut que
j'accélère donc enfin je le sens non
c'est parce que avec mes châtaignes on
se connaît bien ça fait plus de 20 ans
donc c'est pour ça que je le voyais
commencer à m'envoyer des petits signaux
donc je vais juste parler c'est dommage
que j'allais parler d'un domaine qui est
un domaine de prédilection le tout de
suite à l'humain voilà donc le capital
humain donc le capital humain qui est
évidemment la nécessité absolue bien sûr
pour ça former d'abord les jeunes et les
moins jeunes sur ces transitions et
c'est évident alors oui on parle par des
voitures bon vous savez que je me suis
beaucoup battu moi pour qu'on continue à
fabriquer des moteurs thermiques en
Europe et continuent à battre pour ça
parce que bien sûr on a maintenant on a
maintenant décidé donc quand je dis 11
et qui hein c'est le Parlement européen
et c'est les États membres donc c'est
pas la commission qui décide je rappelle
que qui vote qui fait les lois dans
notre démocratie européenne c'est le
Parlement et c'est le conseil le Conseil
européen il est constitué évidemment des
États membres je vais faire une analogie
je sais que c'est un peu osé peut-être
dans cette maison mais c'est un peu
l'équivalent donc de je dirais dans les
démocraties parlementaires en démocratie
parlementaire dans les démocratie
continentale
aux États-Unis on n'a pas du tout un
État fédéral mais il y a une chambre qui
représente les états il y a une chambre
qui représente le peuple et chez nous il
y a évidemment le peuple dans son
acceptation totale et représentée par le
Parlement européen évidemment et les
États membres c'est le Conseil européen
ce sont les collégisateurs c'est eux qui
ont la force de collégiation et donc oui
oui c'est important de le rappeler parce
que je je veux juste te dire que sur
cette question c'est effectivement le
Parlement et le Conseil qui ont décidé
l'arrêt donc de vendre des véhicules
thermiques en 2035
moi je dis simplement il faut peut-être
que on continue en fabriquer aussi sur
notre territoire même si c'est plus pour
les vendre chez nous parce qu'on est 445
millions sur 9 milliards d'habitants
parce qu'il faut aussi continuer à en
vendre le plus propre possible à ceux
qui en ont besoin pour effectuer cette
transition et c'est dans ce contexte
qu'il faut aussi accompagner la
formation de ceux qui faisaient des
véhicules thermiques à des véhicules
électriques c'est une toute autre métier
il faut l'accompagner la formation est
extraordinairement importante on a créé
des académies spécifiques pour ça on a
créé donc des moyens extrêmement
importants avec mon collègue Nicolas
Schmitt pour accompagner ces transitions
dans ce qu'on appelle le Pacte des
compétences vous savez que le marché
intérieur est constitué de 14
écosystèmes industriels
l'automobile l'aviation la santé les
industrie de défense enfin tout ce qui
concerne nos grands secteurs industriels
ces écosystèmes industriels c'est
évidemment les grands groupes mais aussi
toutes les PME qui les constitu ou les
moyens d'entreprises les centres
universitaires les centres de recherche
et chacun a des dynamiques propres de
transformation donc de formation donc je
serai heureux de vous en parler mais je
vais peut-être arrêter parce que pour
laisser la place aux questions c'est un
sujet sachez-le extrêmement extrêmement
important sur lequel on a mis beaucoup
de moyens y compris à la disposition des
États membres conclusion de tout cela
on va présenter je voulais vous le dire
aussi dans quelques jours à un agenda de
sécurité économique la sécurité
économique que vous allez beaucoup en
entendre parler
si vous aviez entendu parler et j'en
doute pas évidemment de la façon dont
fonctionne notre démocratie continentale
là je suis pas sûr que j'en ai entendu
parler c'est la première fois que je le
dis c'est l'agenda de sécurité
économique sur lequel on va présenter un
texte une proposition de texte et de
communication dans les 15 jours qui
viennent je serai heureux de vous en
parler si vous le voulez donc dans les
questions d'un sujet important
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire avant tout propos je tiens
au nom du groupe Renaissance à vous
remercier de votre présence de vos deux
commissions aujourd'hui réunies et nous
mesurons l'opportunité d'échanger
je dirais en prenant de la hauteur
géopolitique c'est aussi important
aujourd'hui nous l'avons vu l'Union
européenne accorde une priorité accrue à
la sécurité économique avant de défendre
les actifs stratégiques européens le
contexte international marque un retour
de la compétition entre grande puissance
et il est essentiel pour l'union de
prendre en compte ces enjeux de sécurité
économique le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron a récemment appelé à
adopté une nouvelle doctrine en matière
de souveraineté économique lors de son
discours à l'Institut Nexus donc en
avril dernier il a soulitié l'importance
de maintenir un marché commun ouvert
tout en étant capable de repousser les
investissements hostiles dans les dans
les secteurs critiques ces propos font
écho au discours de Madame ursila
vanderlione sur les relations entre
l'Union européenne et la Chine en mars
dernier la Commission européenne devrait
présenter une nouvelle stratégie de
sécurité économique ou un agenda de
sécurité pour l'année 2023 bien que des
détails spécifiques n'est pas encore été
divulguées alors cette feuille de route
devrait identifier les secteurs
considérés comme critiques pour la
souveraineté économique de l'Union et
clarifier comment les différents
dispositifs existants seront articulés
dans ce contexte alors Monsieur le
Commissaire
comment devrait se décliner la nouvelle
stratégie de sécurité économique ou
l'agenda de sécurité communique comme
vous l'avez dit et puis vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure comment sortir de cette
naïveté coupable et quels sont les
secteurs prioritaires pour la
souveraineté économique de l'Union
européenne je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame Lepez Monsieur le
Commissaire en deux minutes du coup deux
minutes je vais me consacrer uniquement
si vous le permettez d'avoir merci de
vos propos liminaires madame le député
et sur
l'aspect donc je l'ai pas évoqué tout à
l'heure donc ça me permet de le faire
sur tout ce qui concerne les composants
critiques en fait quand on parle de
sécurité des systèmes
d'approvisionnement y compris pour les
doubles transitions il y a évidemment on
le sait tous maintenant besoin d'un
certain nombre de matériaux spécifiques
et de composants et évidemment de
minerais en particulier tout le monde a
évidemment little en tête le cobalt le
cuivre
les l'ensemble des terres rares etc et
là il faut avoir pour beaucoup d'entre
elles du reste on est là encore
dépendant à je pense en particulier par
exemple au lycam raffiné à plus de 90%
de la Chine alors que la Chine ne
produit enfin commencer l'extra un
extrait que peu de lithium mais le
raffine chez eux donc on a toute une
stratégie on a identifié les chaînes de
valeur dans beaucoup de domaines qui
sont aujourd'hui importantes pour nous
donc et pour lesquels on va proposer
donc une stratégie de diversification de
aussi de relocalisation d'un certain
nombre de composants il y a aussi
l'aspect minerai nous avons décidé que à
l'horizon 2010 2030 pardon ont souhaité
qu'au moins 10% maintenant de
l'extraction face en Europe il y a
beaucoup de candidats de pays candidats
de lieu candidats à ces extractions les
temps sont extrêmement longs pour avoir
les autorisations tout en respectant
évidemment l'ensemble de nos critères
spécifiques évidemment et à nous en
Europe notamment en matière de
protection environnementale et de
biodiversité mais donc on a toutes ces
éléments qui vont qui vont composer donc
la réponse alors on avait une discussion
hier précisément avec avec homologues
américains dans le cadre du TTC donc on
s'est mis tous les 6 semaines tous les 6
mois pardon et les Américains mais
pourquoi vous désignez pas uniquement la
Chine parce que la Chine il y a pas on
n'a pas c'est c'est le problème de
sécurité économique ne dépendent pas que
de la Chine la Chine est un des grands
acteurs mais on a une vision globale de
façon encore une fois à augmenter notre
souveraineté et notre autonomie dans ces
secteurs clés pour éviter finalement de
remplacer une dépendance par une autre
merci beaucoup
merci la parole est à Aurélien Lopez
vigori pour le groupe rassemblement
national
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Commissaire breton d'être
présent aujourd'hui au début de l'année
les Américains ont voté le invention
réduction actes qui leur permet de
soutenir leurs entreprises à grands
coups de commandes publiques et de
subventions en parallèle l'Union
européenne pousse des cris d'orfray en
découvrant un pays peut être souverain
et protéger son industrie disons le lieu
est pris au dépourvu elle patauge et
comme réponse certains évoquent le
baille européenne actes qu'on atteint
toujours et si aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas un équivalent à cela ou un bail
American a au Bay américain actes ou au
Small Business Act c'est parce que le
droit de la concurrence de lieu nous
étouffe tout d'abord les règles notre
commande publique rendent très difficile
voire impossible pour l'état de priorité
des acteurs nationaux ou européens dans
sa commande publique s'ajoute à cela des
règles laxistes sur les investissements
étrangers si une entreprise étrangère
veut racheter une entreprise française
européenne va racheter une entreprise
française l’étape s'oppose à cette
opération seulement si elle fait partie
de la liste des secteurs stratégiques
qui est dès qui est dressé par le
décrirement de bourg avec cette logique
restrictive il est impossible pour
l'état de protéger les entreprises dans
un secteur qui n'est pas encore
considéré au moment du rachat comme
stratégique et en fait vous avez le
contrôle des concentrations qui freine
encore plus la possibilité pour les
entreprises européennes de monter en
puissance
pourquoi parce que la politique de
concurrence menée par l'Union ne permet
pas aux grandes entreprises de ce de se
constituer un géant le résultat c'est
que dans
les domaines dans lesquels nous sommes
incapables de rivaliser avec les grands
acteurs américains et chinois sont
nombreux même trop nombreux dans le
numérique par exemple vous répétez votre
volonté de créer des gafams Européens
très bien c'est parfait même mais avec
ses règles absurdes comment espérer une
seconde pour voir contrer le monopole
d'Amazon Google qui sont construits sur
la commande publique qui sont construits
sur des monopoles alors Monsieur breton
mes questions sont simples à quand un
droit de la concurrence qui protégera et
privilégiera les entreprises européennes
à quand un droit de la concurrence qui
donnera aux États la possibilité
d'orienter leurs commandes publiques
uniquement vers des acteurs européens et
qu'en lieu ce sera-t-elle enfin d'être
aveuglement soumise à l'idéologie de la
concurrence libre et non faussée merci
merci Monsieur le Commissaire
encore plus caricatural que vous ne
l'avez été
même si vous avez essayé d'être
exhaustif dans votre caricature je
prendrai juste le dernier point non
monsieur le député et je défends
personne ici Amazon et Google ce sont
pas comme vous venez de le dire à
l'instant c'est enregistré développé
grâce à la commande publique c'est
totalement faux ah non non non amazon ne
sait absolument pas développé grâce à la
commande publique je peux vous le dire
non mais vous avez parlé vous venez de
parler d'Amazon et de Google donc moi je
suis très précis je vous dis non de sur
quoi mais je réponds si vous permettez à
vos questions sur quoi se sont-ils
appuyés pour cela parce que vous savez
développer au début ces grandes
plateformes c'était pas extrêmement
compliqué sur un marché unique numérique
et c'est vrai on l'avait pas il était
fragmenté désormais grâce au dsaedma on
a enfin un seul marché unique deuxième
point je vous rejoins dans certains
domaines sur l'évolution la politique de
concurrence je me suis beaucoup battu
pour ça elle commence à évoluer du reste
puisqu'on fait du ping-pong vous pouvez
me citer un cas depuis que je suis
commissaire où il y a eu une grande
fusion un géant un champion comme vous
le dites qui a été interditori en Europe
juste ou en citerne depuis que je suis
commissaire donc on veille on est en
train de faire évoluer les choses on est
en train de faire évoluer les choses
vous avez raison c'est un sujet
important mais regardez maintenant ce
qu'on a mis sur la table avec le netzia
on a dedans la possibilité qui est
offerte enfin vous avez raison il
fallait le faire c'est fait de
bénéficier des marchés publics pour
pouvoir le faire et d'avoir la souplesse
que vous appeliez de vos vœux donc vous
voyez l'Europe avance
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Commissaire
nous avons donc maintenant Monsieur
Manuel Bompard pour le groupe LFI c'est
à vous merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Commissaire merci de votre
présence chers collègues contrairement à
ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure la
France et le continent européen ne cesse
malheureusement de ce désindustrialiser
la part de l'industrie manufacturière
est ainsi passé de 18% du PIB de l'Union
européenne en 2000 à seulement 15% en
2021 et le phénomène s'accélère les
indices des directeurs d'achat de ce
mois de mai montre une contraction
continue du secteur industriel vous avez
vous avez certes pris un certain nombre
d'initiatives mais Monsieur le
Commissaire celle-ci échoueront si elle
ne s'attaque pas aux angles morts
qu'elle comporte premier angle mort la
mise en concurrence généralisée des
industries et des travailleurs au sein
même de l'Union européenne sur 752
délocalisations dans le secteur
manufacturier entre 2003 et 2016 près de
la moitié sont imputables à une
délocalisation au sein de l'Union et un
fossé c'est créer d'une part l'Allemagne
et les pays d'Europe centrale et de
l'autre d'autres parts les pays du Sud
vous devriez être sensible à ce constat
de France stratégie la France est parmi
les grands pays industrialisés celui qui
a subi la plus forte des
industrialisations durant les dernières
décennies faisant notre pays l'économie
la plus désindustrialisée du G7 après le
Royaume-Uni et vous le savez
malheureusement les fonds européens
contribuent parfois à se déshabillage de
l'industrie française par exemple le
site de bridge Stone à betwin a été
fermé parce que mise en concurrence avec
un site polonais qui a bénéficié de 24
millions d'euros d'aide dans le cadre du
FEDER deuxième angle mort le refus
d'instaurer un protectionnisme
écologique et solidaire aux frontières
de l'Union européenne les États-Unis et
la Chine pratiquent le protectionnisme
et le soutien massif à leur industrie à
tout va et votre commission demeure
malheureusement libre échangiste
troisième angle mort votre absence
devrait réforme des règles budgétaires
européennes et du régime des aides
d'État sur le premier point tant que
vous maintiendrez les règles du pacte de
stabilité vous créer une situation
certains États européens peuvent
soutenir massivement leur industrie en
l'occurrence l'Allemagne et les autres
ne le peuvent pas aggravant ainsi les
déséquilibres déjà existants sur le
deuxième point vous assouplissez certes
les règles relatives aux aides d'État
mais si vous ne les conditionnez pas à
des objectifs sociaux et
environnementaux vous allez monter
uniquement les profits des actionnaires
et rien d'autre la France d'Emmanuel
Macron est championne à la matière avec
157 milliards d'euros d'être public par
an et se constat de France stratégie les
grandes entreprises françaises sont donc
devenus les championnes de la
délocalisation ce qui leur a permis de
maintenir leur compétitivité au niveau
mondial mais au détriment de l'emploi
industriel en France Monsieur le
Commissaire vous avez dit c'est la fin
de l'Europe naïve alors je vous prends
au mot qu'est-ce que vous avez prévu de
faire contre ces angles morts merci
beaucoup en une minute trente Monsieur
le Commissaire
[Musique]
dans le domaine des véhicules il y a
énormément de réindustrialisation et
voyez si je partage votre analyse sur le
fait qu'il y a eu aussi par le passé des
délocalisations intracommunautaire je
revois maintenant un inversion de
tendance très forte par rapport à mes
propos liminaires cela
réindustrialisation de l'ensemble des
pays qui veulent maintenant reconstituer
leur base industrielle donc si sur la
politique de concurrence et je rejoins
aussi ce qui a été dit il y avait
effectivement des choses à faire on est
en train de le faire évoluer dans un
sens qui va je crois
dans un combat que nous partageons
conjointement qui est la
réindustrialisation de l'Europe merci
merci la parole est à Louise Morel pour
le groupe démocrate merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur les présidents
Monsieur le Commissaire européen cher
collègue au nom du groupe démocrate je
voudrais
vous présente ce matin à l'Assemblée
nationale et pour votre première exposé
passionnant je suis membre à la fois de
la commission des affaires économiques
et des affaires européennes et donc j'en
profite pour me réjouir de voir nos deux
commissions réunies ce matin je crois
qu'il est important de le saluer car
nous le savons une grande partie de la
réponse au défi devant nous se trouve
bien entendu à l'échelle européenne il
en est ainsi de la question de notre
souveraineté économique qui ne peut que
se penser en relation étroite avec nos
autres partenaires européens je souhaite
vous interroger ce matin sur la question
de l'intelligence artificielle on a eu
il y a deux jours à l'Assemblée
nationale en coloc passionnant sur le
sujet et pour prolonger les échanges
enclenchés je voudrais avoir votre
vision sur la manière d'encadrer l'usage
de l'intelligence artificielle et
qu'elle souveraineté européenne nous
pouvons avoir dans ce domaine nous avons
récemment vu le développement de l'usage
de tchadjipiti qui nous amène à repenser
nos modes de travail d'éducation parfois
et d'organisation de certains modes de
production et plus particulièrement je
voudrais vous interroger sur la question
de gratuit ou payant à chat gipiti ou à
d'autres intelligences artificielles la
version de base de l'algorithme est
gratuit sa version Premium et désormais
payante et il existe donc un risque de
se voir de voir demain se creuser des
inégalités entre ceux qui pourront
s'offrir les services de l'intelligence
artificielle et ceux qui ne pourront pas
avec un avantage comparatif
irrattrapable des premiers sur les
secondes à l'heure où nous parlons
régulièrement de fracture numérique
d'accès à deux vitesses demain on
pourrait ainsi avoir cette nouvelle
fracture sociale donc quel regard
portez-vous sur l'accès à l'intelligence
artificielle pour tous et plus
globalement comment l'Union européenne
peut-elle garantir sa souveraineté
industrielle propre dans ce domaine et
sur le sujet de chat ipty qui est
américain il semble déjà avoir séduit en
grand nombre de concitoyens avons-nous
déjà pris trop de retard dans ce domaine
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Commissaire pour deux
minutes
sur un sujet extrêmement important qui
concerne la régulation donc de
l'intelligence artificielle je voudrais
vous dire que au niveau européen on
travaille depuis mes premiers jours de
ma prise de fonction sur cette question
ça faisait partie effectivement de
l'ensemble de tout ce que je souhaitais
porter donc devant le Parlement européen
est devant le Conseil européen d'accéder
à nos collégisateurs pour structurer
notre espace numérique notre espace
informationnel
nous avons donc
constitué comme je le fais
systématiquement une très très large
on n'est pas participer à une très très
large consultation donc au début donc de
mes prises de fonction sur ces questions
comme d'habitude pendant plusieurs mois
tout le monde ait répondu toutes les
entreprises les états etc concernés on a
donc maintenant proposé notre on appelle
ça le i intelligence artificiel Act donc
l'acte d'intelligence artificielle qui a
été donc maintenant votée par le Conseil
il est maintenant en discussion au
Parlement européen le européen doit
prendre sa position finale je crois au
mois de juin et à ce moment là le texte
rentrera donc en trilogue pour devenir
donc notre texte de régulation et de
protection d'intelligence artificielle
donc on est très avancé alors évidemment
je vais pas répondre à l'ensemble de vos
questions toutes ces questions sont
aujourd'hui en réponse dansaient déjà
dans ce texte si certains veulent encore
les amandes le Parlement européen a
encore la possibilité de proposer ses
amendements notamment sur l'intelligence
artificielle générative à laquelle vous
faites allusion parle de chat GPT mais
il y a beaucoup d'autres intelligence
générative donc aujourd'hui qui vont
exister qui vont se développer donc on a
une régulation qui est une régulation
donc en quatre niveaux pour la
synthétiser il y a d'abord tout ce qui
est tout ce qui est offre des risques
minimaux c'est une c'est une régulation
qui est proposée qui sur les risques et
sur l'évaluation des données
intelligence artificielle c'est trois
choses ce sont les données ce sont les
algorithmes et c'est la puissance de
calcul et c'est donc les données donc
qui vont à qualifier donc on a les
intelligences artificielles à risque
minimal les intelligence artificielle
qui peuvent avoir par exemple comme des
bottes ou tout ce qui concerne les deep
fake donc qui ont un autre niveau de
régulation les intelligences
artificielles à risque comme par exemple
tout ce qui concerne la santé le
recrutement etc qui vont être permis
selon des critères extrêmement stricts
et puis celles qui seront inacceptables
et prohibés comme par exemple ce qu'on
appelle le social scoring des autres
donc ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
regarder ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au
niveau européen un travail considérable
a été fait on est les premiers au monde
à l'avoir fait ça couvre toutes ces
questions que vous posez légitimement si
vous avez encore des sujets ou des
petites questions utilisées vos députés
européens pour faire passer aux
amendements on est en phase finale et le
texte je l'espère sera voté au second
semestre j'en parlais hier encore avec
les Américains on est effectivement les
premiers à l'avoir fait mais on y
travaille depuis quatre ans merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Marietta
karamani pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le Président mais
Messieurs les Présidents Monsieur le
Commissaire alors je voulais revenir
peut-être sur la question de de rapport
entre la Russie et l'Ukraine enfin
l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine
justement qui nous démontre plus que
jamais que la nécessité et l'urgence de
l'autonomie stratégique européenne et de
l'Union et il n'y a pas donc que la
Russie qui menace notre souveraineté
économique nous voulons aussi nous
devons éviter une dépendance à ce sens
unique et donc de négociations sont en
cours sur les textes importants comme le
shipac ou l'instrument d'achat conjoint
d'armement et il y a aussi l'annonce
d'un règlement sur les matières
critiques donc le projet donc de fonds
de souveraineté également évoqué par la
Commission européenne est utile aussi
pour financer nos actions en la matière
et nous devons donc plus clairement
penser ce que relève du partenariat de
la concurrence économique et de rivalité
systémique nous devons aussi réfléchir
ensemble de la façon dont nous acceptons
certains investissements étrangers dont
nous acceptons la propriété étrangère et
la qualité d'opérateurs
d'infrastructures considéré comme
stratégie ou critique ça veut dire que
il faut je pense s'ouvrir une réflexion
à la fois pour définir ce qui sont les
secteurs produits comparatifs composants
stratégiques pour l'Union européenne
mais aussi déterminer de nouvelles
règles d'investissement dans l'Union
européenne avec deux guidances la
sécurité et la réciprocité du pays
investisseurs en pharmacien d'adoption
Monsieur le Commissaire de nouvelles
règles budgétaires au niveau de l'Union
et nous avons vu que n'a pas été
suffisamment prise en compte la
transition énergétique les coûts énormes
qui s'attachent à cette transition
conditions de notre souveraineté doivent
mieux être pris en compte et ces
réflexions il est temps que les
parlements nationaux les partages les
envisages de les suivre donc sur ces
trois axes aspects je dirais
détermination de secteurs stratégiques
définition des règles d'investissement
et prise en compte de la transition
énergétique dans l'évolution des règles
budgétaires pouvez-vous nous donner et
vos axes de travail et vos propositions
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Commissaire
pour deux minutes 45 allez-y merci merci
j'ai rêvé un instant de
ça me permettra également de répondre à
une question à laquelle j'avais pas
répondu à
l'interpellation interrogation de
Monsieur Bompard sur la capacité
d'intervenir y compris ces entreprises
stratégiques à travers le fond de
souveraineté car effectivement nous
défendons la mise en œuvre de la front
de souveraineté qui doit pouvoir
intervenir à la fois donc en soutien
d'un certain nombre d'entreprises de
secteurs stratégiques on peut parler en
particulier la santé vous avez pas
l'énergie mais des secteurs qui sont
critiques et puis également de pouvoir
intervenir si jamais on
ça fait défaut un instrument pour
pouvoir intervenir si jamais on voit
qu'il y a une entreprise particulière
qui peut jouer un rôle très stratégique
voir systémique au sein d'une chaîne de
valeur et pouvoir
l'acheter pour éviter que celle-ci ne
parte dans des mains
on n'aurait pas la possibilité de
l'interdire donc on se donne ces
instruments et j'espère vivement que à
l'occasion du fond de souveraineté on
aura une grande partie de la réponse aux
questions que vous vous posez pour le
reste
comme je l'ai dit on a fait toute cette
cartographie cette cartographie des
dépendances vous parliez tout à l'heure
de la notion de ripal systémique vous
via l'usure évidemment en directement à
la Chine puisque la Chine est qualifiée
depuis la commission yunker de rival
systémique derrière il fallait pouvoir
le nourrir qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
c'est dans ce que j'appelais tout à
l'heure cette politique de de minimie de
minimisation des risques donc des
riskins on dit ça c'est un mot qui donc
je préfère dire minimiser les risques
minimiser nos dépendances élargir nos
sources d'approvisionnement donc tout
ceci fait partie vous le verrez dans le
critical rematériel Act le C RMA qui
donc défend nos
sources d'approvisionnement en matériaux
critique le chipack il a été voté il est
maintenant en cours donc ça c'est
derrière nous et le nasadia qui est
d'une certaine façon la réponse à l'IRA
qui répond aussi à un nombre important
de vos interrogations merci beaucoup
merci la parole est Christophe Plassard
pour le groupe horizon
merci Messieurs les Présidents Monsieur
le Commissaire ces derniers mois j'ai
mené des travaux d'une mission
d'information sur l'économie de guerre
comme commissaire aux finances et
rapporteur de budget de la défense qui
démontrait notamment que la souveraineté
de notre pays passait par la réindustrie
réalisation de nos moyens de production
stratégique ce qui recoupe je le sais
des travaux que vous avez récemment
menés en tant que commissaire européen
au Marché intérieur malheureusement nous
n'avons pas pu vous éditionner ou votre
cabinet donc j'en profite pour vous
poser deux questions sur ces sujets la
première est celle de savoir comment
l'Union européenne appréhende cette
nécessité de relocalisation dans
l'industrie de défense afin de sécuriser
nos chaînes d'approvisionnement des
mutualisations stratégiques sont-elles
envisagées et comment percevez-vous les
coopérations actuelles que sont le Scaff
et le mgcs ma seconde question Monsieur
le Commissaire concerne plus
spécifiquement le financement de
l'industrie de la défense il éprouvait
aujourd'hui que les entreprises du
secteur de la did font face à une
défiance de la part des banques et des
institutions financières l'Union
européenne avait un projet de texte
excluant explicitant le secteur
explicitement pardon le secteur de la
défense des investissements jugés
acceptables forte heureusement ou fort
malheureusement
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie a
mis ce projet au placard du moins
temporairement par ailleurs la Banque
européenne d'investissement la BEI
exclut déjà et encore aujourd'hui de ces
statuts le financement des industries de
défense en tant que commissaire européen
au Marché intérieur et compte tenu de
l'importance de la BITD pour notre
industrie et notre souveraineté
stratégique pas seulement nationale mais
européenne quelle est votre action face
à cette lame de fond et comment la
France peut-elle faire à nouveau rentrer
le secteur de la défense dans le champ
des investissements responsables on sait
en effet qu'il ne peut y avoir de
durabilité de nos modèles démocratiques
sans une défense crédible et que l'on
connaît le poids des ONG sur les
institutions et leurs intérêts face aux
industries stratégiques je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Commissaire pour un
peu plus de 2 minutes
je vais prendre la deuxième question la
deuxième partie de votre question qui
remontera la première c'est un sujet sur
lequel je me suis penché dès le début le
financement donc je vous rassure tout de
suite
je le dis peut-être de façon un peu vous
allez penser exagéré tant que très
commissaire il y aura pas de texte que
vous l'avez vu il y en a pas donc je
vous rassure tout ce que vous lisez
c'est des fausses fuites il y aura
jamais un texte qui va dire que on
favorise ou en défavorise le financement
d'un industrie de défense c'est faux
croyez moi j'y veille deuxième point
vous avez raison il faut absolument que
les indices que le monde financier
s'adapte à cette nouvelle réalité parce
qu'au fond financer des industries de
défense c'est financer aussi notre
souveraineté notre autonomie et notre
démocratie et donc je suis de ceux qui
demandent à liker demander explicitement
sa figure désormais dans le dans le
texte que nous sommes en train de
débattre le texte ASAP donc qui a été
donc débattue maintenant au Parlement
européen et au conseil en urgence
puisque c'est le Parlement européen qui
a voté l'urgence pour avoir une réponse
dans les deux mois pour augmenter notre
base industrielle donc de fabrication de
munitions comme vous le savez j'ai
explicitement mis dedans le fait que la
BU devait désormais pouvoir financer je
rappelle que la BU est au service des
politiques de l'Union que rien ne
l'interdit contrairement à ce que vous
venez de dire rien ne lui interdit que
aujourd'hui il y a eu des habitudes qui
étaient prises auparavant donc j'ai vu
moi-même l'ensemble des responsables de
la BU il y a plusieurs reprises pour
leur demander désormais de s'adapter aux
politiques de l'Union dans la défense
fait partie voilà donc je mets mais il
faut aussi que l'ensemble des ce qui
siègent au conseil de la BU c'est à dire
les ministres des Finances je m'en suis
ouvert directement à le maire votre bien
dans ce sens pour que la BU désormais
participe s'il avait y participe on sait
bien que ça aura un effet d'entraînement
très important dans l'ensemble du
secteur financiers c'est pour ça que
j'ai mené cette démarche vous le
comprenez bien et sur le deuxième le
premier point on a une base industrielle
aujourd'hui on sait tout faire en Europe
on sait tout faire en matière d'armement
tout le problème c'est qu'on ne va pas
assez vite et le problème c'est qu'on a
pas assez de capacités industrielles
donc quand les industriels vous disent
il y a pas de problème je sais tout
faire mais c'est quand la livraison dans
4 ans et ben ça correspond plus à nos
besoins d'où la nécessité de monter nos
capacités de production industrielle
pour faire face à nos besoins nouveaux
chaque État membre doit désormais en
particulier ceux qui font partie de
l'OTAN et ils sont pratiquement tous
membres de l'OTAN y compris la France
bien entendu
au minimum dépenser 2% de son PMB en
matière de défense vous le savez c'est
la règle ça veut dire évidemment avoir
un outil industriel qui s'adapte à ces
demandes nouvelles faute de quoi les
États membres vont aller acheter là
aussi disponible donc on a tout c'est la
bonne nouvelle il faut travailler
beaucoup plus ensemble il faut
travailler beaucoup plus ensemble les
coopérations sont en route il faut les
soutenir et nous avons des instruments
aussi que soit les instruments œdipe et
dire pas au hasard qui favorise
désormais et le Fonds européen de
défense comme vous le savez qui favorise
la mutualisation le fait ensemble que
quand quatre pays se mettent ensemble et
bien ils bénéficie d'un soutien accru
pour précisément favoriser ces
rapprochements auxquels vous faisiez à
juste titre allusion merci beaucoup
Monsieur le Commissaire je vous propose
de passer madame Julie leernos pour le
groupe écologiste
Messieurs les Présidents
Monsieur le Commissaire européen vous
êtes commissaire européen du marché
intérieur de la souveraineté
industrielle européenne et non un
commissaire uniquement français puisque
vous l'avez dans votre petit cours sur
les institutions européennes explicité
l'État français est représenté au
Conseil européen ainsi qu'au Parlement
européen via ses députés j'ai trouvé
particulièrement choquant dans vos
propos introductifs de remettre en cause
une décision prise par le Parlement
européen et le Conseil sur la fin des
véhicules thermiques ça pour moi outre
passe le rôle d'un commissaire européen
comment un commissaire européen peut-il
prôner de contourner cette
réglementation pour continuer à produire
des véhicules thermiques polluants en
France vous savez que la crise
climatique ne connaît pas de frontière
et que ou que ce soit les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sont émis il
contribue au même réchauffement
climatique que nous subissons toutes
sur par rapport à vos propos sur la
question du nucléaire là aussi l'Union
européenne est extrêmement divisée sur
le sujet aujourd'hui l'Espagne a fait
savoir clairement à la France qu'ils ne
souhaitait pas que l'hydrogène rose soit
pris pour de l'hydrogène verte et
refuserait de fournir de l'électricité à
la France pour produire de l'hydrogène
si tel était le cas il me semble qu'il
faut avoir dans votre rôle une vision
européenne et pas seulement une visio
très franco-française et une croyance
absolue dans la question du nucléaire
alors pour revenir sur la question
industrielle oui nous avons fortement
besoin d'une industrie européenne forte
pour mener le front les défis auxquels
nous faisons face vous l'avez évoqué le
fiasco européen sur les énergies
renouvelables et notamment l'abandon de
la filière du photovoltaïque et
extrêmement nocive aujourd'hui en France
je crois qu'il est encore deux
entreprises françaises qui ont résisté
dans un en Loire-Atlantique qui doit
chaque année réinvestir dans ces
machines puisque les cellules sont
uniquement produites en Chine c'est ça
la réalité aujourd'hui la
désindustrialisation et comment l'Union
européenne et la France ont abandonné y
compris leur propre industrie dite verte
alors il y a deux textes effectivement
où les avez évoqué le net 0 in the show
mais en même temps nous avons pas
réellement l'impression entre
le le prenage du nucléaire mais
également que veut dire réellement les
le net 0 c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on va
investir massivement dans les stratégies
de capture de carbone plutôt que dans
une filière dont on sait qu'elle est
l'avenir et dont elle est sec elle est
importante pour notre souveraineté qui
est les énergies renouvelables je pense
qu'il ne faut pas troquer nos
dépendances indésirables actuelles
contre de nouvelles troquer le libre
commerce et la libre concurrence contre
le commerce durable et équitable
avez-vous conscience de la nécessité
absolue de changer de paradigme merci
Monsieur le Commissaire madame Arnaud je
vous laisse une minute pour répondre
pardonne une minute madame la député
dans le dialogue démocratique que nous
menons ce matin
je suis choqué moi aussi de ce que vous
venez de dire
je n'ai jamais dit que je prenais
l'arrêt de la commercialisation en
Europe ou la vente la poursuite de la
commercialisation en Europe de moteur
thermique j'ai dit si vous permettez
j'ai dit je prône
deux choses d'abord de respecter
effectivement le fait qu'après 2035 on
ne pourra plus vendre en Europe de
moteur thermique sauf des fiouls comme
vous le savez
mais j'ai dit je prône et c'est là je
suis choqué que nous puissions au moins
continuer à vendre pour à produire pour
ceux qui le veulent des moteurs
thermiques propres pour des pays qui
voudraient en avoir besoin plutôt que le
SS marché qui sera marché parce que vous
voyez en 2050 en 2050 sur la planète il
y aura encore 70% des véhicules qui
seront thermiques et bien moi je préfère
qu'il soit vendu par des entreprises
européennes qui utilisent des normes
recette très propre pour les pays qui en
auront besoin pour faire leur transition
à leur propre rythme voilà ce que j'ai
dit je suis choqué de votre
interprétation merci beaucoup merci la
parole est à André Cassagne pour le
groupe Geder
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire je voudrais revenir sur ce
que j'appelle un impérialisme juridique
c'est
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
et qui a des conséquences sur
l'industrialisation de l'Union
européenne aussi et sur des
interventions d'entreprises
d'entreprises françaises européennes
dans un état comme Cuba qui est soumis
aujourd'hui à un embargo c'est extrater
extraterritorialité aboutit en fait un
véritable blocus parce que les
américains avec une batterie de loi qui
ont été mises en oeuvre avec des
contrôles prises qui qui très précis sur
le sur nos banques sur nos entreprises
se permettent d'interdire et de
racketter des entreprises qui veulent
travailler avec un état tel que Cuba en
15 ans c'est 50 milliards de pénalités
ça va dalcatel que vous connaissez bien
ça devait être autour de 137 millions
d'euros à PNB Paribas ce qui était 8,
milliards d'euros de pénalité alors je
me dis tout ça ça interdit par exemple
des de vendre des produits qui ont plus
de 10% de composantes américaines c'est
le fait que on passe de plus le parle
dollar le ça donne une puissance
terrible une puissance terrible aux
États-Unis alors que l'euro l'euro n'est
sans doute pas à la est plutôt en perte
de vitesse mais c'est peut-être pas le
cas vous le direz dans les échanges dans
les échanges internationaux donc ma
question est la suivante il existe
depuis notamment depuis 1996 euh un
règlement de blocage au niveau de
l'Union européenne qui semble-t-il n'est
jamais mise en oeuvre mais peut-être que
vous vous avez quelques exemples à
donner comment on pourrait faire pour
que des états pour des entreprises qui
veulent commercer qui veulent avoir des
accords économiques comme la France
d'ailleurs essaie d'en avoir et
aujourd'hui certains sont bloquées avec
un pays comme Cuba comment faire pour
cet extraterritorialité de droit
américain soit enfin bloqué parce que
c'est bien un impérialisme juridique il
y a de lourdes conséquences
c'est le commissaire pour deux minutes
d'abord
[Musique]
sans reprendre peut-être les
termes que vous venez d'évoquer
on a tous connu
ces sujets où il y avait une sorte
d'extraterritorialité moi je l'ai connu
en particulier dans le domaine par
exemple des données donc
et c'est un sujet
qui a concerné beaucoup d'entreprises
qui sont qui s'en sont émus à juste
titre et là donc je vais le dire parce
que c'est un sujet quand même qui couvre
maintenant 40% de l'économie c'est très
très important on a mis maintenant des
règles et notamment donc avec la rgpd
puis maintenant avec tout ce qu'on fait
sur le DSA ldma pour précisément que les
juridictions qui s'appliquent sur ce qui
est traité en Europe soit uniquement
exclusivement des juridictions
européennes c'est très important parce
qu'effectivement ça pouvait ça pouvait
amener à des situations telles que vous
les évoquez dans le domaine
sur le rôle le rôle de l'euro oui il
faut absolument que l'euro joue un rôle
très important dans les échanges alors
je voulais vous dire que pour aborder
pour commencer à répondre à la
problématique large que vous venez de de
de soulever on travaille avec un sujet
qui est extrêmement important qui est
l'euro numérique
qui doit nous permettre sur le volet
financier d'être beaucoup plus
indépendant notamment des grands acteurs
américains et donc
en faisant référence au cas d'excès que
vous venez d'évoquer donc voilà on a des
pistes c'est un sujet extrêmement large
que vous soulevez
sachez que en tant que commissaire au
marché intérieur je dans toutes les
régulations et les règles dont je suis
le garant ou donc je suis le
rédacteur je veille à ce que pour toutes
les activités ce soit uniquement les
régulations européennes qui s'appliquent
en Europe mais c'est un sujet qui est un
sujet important et donc je suis aussi un
sujet de préoccupation que je partage
avec vous
parfait vous avez vu monsieur chaseigne
ça fonctionne très bien merci beaucoup
Monsieur le Commissaire merci beaucoup
pour vos réponses maintenant on va
passer aux questions individuelles des
députés donc cette fois-ci je vais
prendre toutes les questions
individuelles
l'une après l'autre et ensuite Monsieur
le Commissaire vous pourrez répondre et
conclure à votre guise une minute par
question c'est une minute par question
de nos intervenants de nos députés je
vous propose de commencer par Madame
l'hygiène métayer c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire chers collègues comme vous
l'avez rappelé dans vos propres
liminaires passionnants la notion
d'autonomie stratégique est au coeur de
la politique industrielle de l'oignon
européenne alors je travaille
actuellement sur un rapport
d'information dans le cas de la
commission des affaires européennes
portant bilan de portant bilan en fait
sur les accords de libre-échange et j'ai
pu constater avec mon cours rapporteur
certaines difficultés en la matière en
effet la concomitance entre le nouvel
objectif européen de souveraineté et son
effort historique de développement de
libre-échange fait apparaître pour
certains un manque de cohérence
politique cette critique peut notamment
être soulevée en ce qui concerne les
accords les moins récents souvent assez
éloigné de nos objectifs actuels et à ce
sujet la DG trade ne semble par ailleurs
aucunement favorables onéreux
négociation ou à l'ajout de protocoles
additionnels un monsieur le Commissaire
dans cet optique de souveraineté
industrielle européenne quels sont vos
perspectives sur l'articulation entre
notre marché intérieur et les accords
commerciaux externes et quelles
améliorations ations envisagez-vous à
cet égard je vous remercie merci
la parole est taillée elle ménage pour
le groupe rassemblement national
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire chers collègues dans un
contexte mondial qui est en train de
passer du règne sans partage du dollar à
un paradigme économique multi polaire y
compris au plan monétaire forcée de
constater que l'Union européenne semble
être arc-bouté sur le monde ancien l'UE
fait avancer à marche forcée des mesures
inadaptées aux nouveaux enjeux notamment
par une application extrême de politique
environnementale ruineuse pour
l'activité économique ma question
portera souveraineté alimentaire
française et européenne nos industries
agriculteurs et marins pêcheurs
notamment doit faire face à des
concurrences déloyales qui provoquent
leur ruines y compris nos partenaires
d'Amérique du Nord dans ce cadre un
projet de règlement du PE et du Conseil
relatif à la restauration de la nature
envisage entre autres de mettre 10% des
terres agricoles hors production mais
aussi à contraindre encore plus les
capacités de la pêche côtière donc
Monsieur le Commissaire ma question est
simple dans le de votre mandat que
comptez-vous faire pour arrêter ces
mesures dangereuses pour notre nos
économies nationales et européennes
merci merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame Sophia chikiri
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
Messieurs les Présidents Monsieur le
Commissaire selon les critères de l'OCDE
c'est dans les pays de l'Union
européenne que se trouve les régimes les
moins restrictifs du monde vis-à-vis des
idées chaque État membre ayant son
propre système de filtrage voire
carrément pas de système Monsieur le
Commissaire j'ai quelques questions
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelle
piste vous pourriez apporter avec
l'Union européenne pour qu'un vrai
mécanisme de filtrage des IDE soit mis
en place qui aille au-delà du système
d'alerte actuel qui porte pour
l'essentiel sur des questions de
sécurité est-ce que pensez-vous de
l'initiative canadienne d'interdire pour
deux ans au moins les idées immobilières
qui est source qui sont sources de
spéculation dans les zones de
spéculation immobilière pardon dans les
zones tendues par exemple en France 20%
des IDE vont dans l'immobilier comment
comptez-vous enfin lutter pour que soit
en réalité qui sont en réalité de
l'optimisation fiscale en France c'est
10% qui proviennent des pays des
Pays-Bas ou du Luxembourg pour qu'enfin
cela cesse et qu'on cesse de faire du
dumping fiscal au sein de l'Union
européenne enfin toute dernière question
monsieur castoriant s'il vous plaît
comment comptez-vous mettre en place des
idées des des filtrage qui permettent en
fait un filtrage écologique social mais
aussi sur les brevets afin de protéger
les secteurs stratégiques merci beaucoup
pour le temps supplémentaire merci
beaucoup
paroles est à Stéphane Buchoux pour le
groupe Renaissance c'est pour une minute
merci monsieur le Président Messieurs
les Présidents mes chers collègues
Monsieur le Commissaire depuis plusieurs
mois la France et ses voisins européens
font face à une pénurie de médicaments
sans précédent début janvier en Espagne
672 médicaments étaient en rupture de
stock dans les officines en France
l'antibiotique amoxicilline considéré
par l'OMS comme médicament essentiel
était en rupture partout sur le
territoire et notre pays a connu une
forte tension sur le doliprane le
gouvernement tout comme la Commission
européenne sont chacun en train de
dresser une liste d'environ 280
médicaments essentiels qui pourraient
servir de base à une obligation de stock
pour les laboratoires Monsieur le
Commissaire outre cette mesure que
prévoit la Commission européenne pour
pallier cette situation sur le long
terme notamment pour la relocalisation
de la production des principes actifs en
Europe afin d'assurer notre souveraineté
sanitaire merci beaucoup
45 secondes c'est admirable merci
beaucoup la parole est à la Marie-Noëlle
Baptiste pour le PS
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire je souhaite vous interroger
sur la volonté de Bruxelles d'imposer
aux géants du Net une juste contribution
dans le financement des réseaux de
télécom nous avons eu deux tables rondes
dans cette commission à ce sujet les
gars femme sont les plus gros
générateurs de données Internet plus de
la moitié du trafic elle tire donc un
avantage disproportionné d'un réseau
qu'elle ne contribue ni à créer ni à
entretenir à la différence d'opérateurs
pour qu'il a hausse des coûts
d'entretien et dans le perfectionnement
du réseau est exponentielle un coup
estimé à l'échelle de l'Union européenne
entre 36 et 40 milliards en 2021 donc ce
n'est pas neutre notre groupe souhaite a
donc la salut donc la volonté de la
Commission de faire participer ces
acteurs par le biais d'une contribution
financière comme cela a été annoncé
début juin alors Monsieur le Commissaire
pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur le
périmètre le niveau de contrainte le
calendrier du dispositif envisagé é par
la Commission et nous attendons
évidemment que cette contribution soit à
la hauteur des énormes bénéfices qui
sont d'ailleurs souvent optimisés
fiscalement à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne
merci la parole est à Brigitte qu'une
carte pour le groupe Renaissance et pour
une minute si Président Monsieur le
Commissaire l'Europe est confronté à une
montée des mesures protectionnistes qui
sont imposées par les grandes puissances
concurrentes comme les États-Unis la
Chine l'Inde c'est nous nouveau défi
pour notre souveraineté européenne ont
provoqué une réaction rapide que nous
saluons de la commission le net 0
industriacte en est la démonstration la
plus concrète puisqu'il vise à soutenir
les secteurs clés pour favoriser la
décarbonation or bien que l'énergie
nucléaire figure dans le texte en tant
que technologie à émission nette et vous
y avez fortement contribué elle reste à
grande absente de la liste des
technologies stratégiques qu'elles vont
bénéficier d'un soutien particulier ce
choix est difficilement compréhensible
si l'on considère que l'énergie
nucléaire est la première source
d'électricité de l'Union européenne
alors Monsieur le Commissaire pourquoi
ne reconnaît que partiellement le
nucléaire alors même que ce texte a
vocation à soutenir les technologies qui
lui permettront d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone merci beaucoup et
puis on termine cette série de questions
avec monsieur Alexandre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire une fois n'est pas coutume
je vais reprendre le fil de la
l'excellente question de mon collègue
André Chassaigne en 2019 il y a quelques
États membres dans le cas du DCP awak où
on lançait une initiative qui a payé une
steak pour protéger les investissements
et les échanges commerciaux avec
l'Iran
il y a quelques semaines cette
initiative dans la plus grande
discrétion a été totalement abandonnée
alors la situation en Iran c'est dégradé
ça c'est sûr mais surtout l'initiative
objectivement a été un échec il faut
être très clair
dans le monde dans lequel on est on n'a
pas une semaine qui passe sans des
sanctions ou en tout cas que les
tensions entre la Chine et les
États-Unis deviennent de plus en plus
vives avec des régimes de sanctions qui
sont de plus en plus larges sur des
filières et sur des sous-traitants si
j'ai bien compris la réponse que vous
avez donné en effet la seule réponse
pour l'instant que la Commission a c'est
le renumérique
à ce ce champ de sanction qui
potentiellement pourra avoir un impact
majeur sur des filiales d'entreprises
européennes qui pourraient opérer dans
des pays tiers mais quand même sujet à
sanction d'un parti ou de l'autre
d'ailleurs sans viser un parti un parti
particulièrement ou est-ce que la
Commission a une réflexion pour faire un
mécanisme de protection des
investissements à l'étranger qui est
plus solide que celui de Intex et qui
est susceptible de fonctionner à
l'avenir
merci beaucoup y a-t-il d'autres
questions individuelles non et bien
écoutez très bien Monsieur le
Commissaire je vais vous proposer de
répondre à ces questions et conclure
dans le temps qui vous paraîtra
nécessaire
merci beaucoup pour pour ces questions
je vais essayer de les de les reprendre
une par une alors
tout d'abord
une question sur
l'autonomie stratégique la première
c'était la première question sur
l'autonomie stratégique et la politique
commerciale
c'est une question extrêmement
importante
je vais abordé cette question pas plus
tard que hier avec
notre homologue qui est l'ambassadrice
taille donc qui suit ces questions du
côté américain pour lui dire qu'il
fallait effectivement commencer à revoir
notre façon de mener à bien nos
politiques de commerce international
dans la suite internationale là aussi
s'en naïveté et avec un élément qui est
très important c'est la sécurisation des
chaînes d'approvisionnement et les
rapports de force qui doivent être
impliqués dans ces relations parce que
c'est pas parce que on a un accord je
dirais bilatérale quand tout va bien que
celui-ci fonctionne quand tout va mal je
vous ai rappelé tout à l'heure par cette
anecdote ce qui s'était passé dans le
domaine de vaccins donc il faut
maintenant revoir un chantier je le
cache pas parce que vous avez à juste
titre faire référence à l'évolution
géopolitique du monde
voilà nous on existe dans cette dans ce
monde là parce qu'on est incontinent et
parce qu'on est uni effort ensemble et
donc c'est cette unité cette force
ensemble qu'il faut traduire tendre
relation commerciale pour que certains
n'est pas la tentation d'utiliser au
fond des dépendances que l'on crée
lorsqu'on ouvre une voie commerciale
c'est aussi bien entendu c'est l'intérêt
des deux parties ça peut être aussi une
dépendance si jamais les relations
venaient attendre donc on va intégrer
cette notion cette dimension totalement
nouvelle dans le cadre relation
internationale et dans le cadre des
marchés des relations évidemment
commerciales c'est un chantier qu'on a
décidé d'ouvrir pour répondre très
spécifiquement à cette à cette question
extrêmement importante
je vais essayer quand même d'aller assez
vite donc vous m'excusez si je
puisse la deuxième question
concerner un autre point important qui
est la souveraineté alimentaire qui est
aussi un élément évidemment très
important de notre souveraineté
alors ces sujets que vous venez
d'évoquer sont en cours d'être débattus
en train de débattu comme vous le savez
par les collégicateurs donc là encore
c'est aujourd'hui au Parlement et au
conseil donc que ces questions que vous
soulevez tiens juste titre sont soulevés
c'est vraiment important de rappeler que
nos agriculteurs font déjà face à des
enjeux très importants
notamment le réchauffement climatique
les problèmes on a beaucoup parlé je
crois en France en particulier ces
derniers temps sur l'eau
et donc il faut évidemment les
accompagner dans cette transition et
donc voilà j'espère que c'est maintenant
les collisateurs donc j'ai peut-être pu
froisser certains en rappelant le
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes mais c'est vraiment à ce
niveau là que ça doit se passer
maintenant et je pense qu'en fonction
des événements c'est le moment
effectivement si jamais encore une fois
les collagisateurs estiment et c'est pas
la Commission à le dire encore une fois
la commission n'est pas là pour ça c'est
au colisateur à se prononcer c'est sans
doute une question qui serait importante
effectivement d'avoir en tête à l'heure
où les positions sont en train de se
cristalliser d'un côté ou de l'autre de
nos colisateurs sur la troisième
question la troisième question je crois
que c'était sur les
IDE alors sont des investissements
directs étrangers
quelque part vous avez raison dans ces
idées moi quand je disais mes idées
finances on mettait beaucoup de choses
et j'avais un peu de mal au début à m'y
retrouver parce qu'on met beaucoup de
choses mais vous y référence aux
investissements
immobiliers il y avait aussi des
investissements financiers il y a
souvent industriels donc c'est bien
effectivement je trouve dans les vidéos
de regarder un peu plus de façon
segmentée
ce qui se passe ne serait-ce que
poursuivre évidemment
c'est ces investissements
tous les investissements sont les
bienvenus bien sûr après ils ont pas
tous le même impact sur je dirais
l'économie ou l'industrie donc on a mis
en place des instruments donc très fort
là je sais pas si vous les avez bien en
tête sur les filtrage est vraiment c'est
quelque chose qui a été fait et en
particulier donc vous voyez je dis aussi
que c'était fait pas ma collègue ma
grande vestiger donc ça fait son très
très nouveau et plus efficace
pour limiter ses investissements directs
étrangers donc on a maintenant les
instruments donc ils sont ils
pour les limiter si ils sont contraires
aux intérêts européens donc ça y est on
a enfin les instruments maintenant il
faut évidemment les rendre actifs mais
ils existent depuis peu de temps
deuxièmement il y a un sujet qui est
très important qui est sur ça me permet
de rappeler parce que certains ont
évoqué indirectement la question la sur
les sur l'ensemble des chaînes de valeur
je dirais le fait que tout au long de la
chaîne de valeur y est finalement les
mêmes contraintes environnementales ou
sociales qui se déroule pas uniquement
sur la dernière entreprise qui va vendre
mais c'est toutes celles qui en amont
ont contribué à fabriquer par exemple
les produits
et ça c'est très important c'est des
débats qui sont très importants comme
vous le savez moi j'y apporte beaucoup
d'importance pour que la chaîne de
valeur intégrale finalement
comprennent à tout moment
les contraintes que nous nous fixons
nous qu'elles soient environnementales
ou sociale sur le marché intérieur et
qu'on puisse leur monter donc ça c'est
un élément aussi qui est très important
pour limiter effectivement ce que vous
dites et puis dernier point c'est quand
même aussi un sujet très important
voulait peut-être pas évoqué mais il est
il est peut-être un peu en parallèle par
rapport à cette question surtout tout le
travail sur les standards parce que les
standards derrière c'est évidemment
c'est un standard c'est technologique
mais ça c'est beaucoup plus large
désormais et ça couvre beaucoup
d'aspects et compris sur les je dirais
obligations que nous nous imposons en
particulier en matière environnementale
mais pas que donc là il y a un travail
qui est très important à faire et qui va
je crois dans le sens que vous appeliez
de vos vœux sur ce fameux contrôle
filtrage des idées mais je repris un sur
la première partie votre question je
pense qu'il serait intéressant d'avoir
une segmentation plus fine de étape par
état de l'ensemble de ce que constitue
en général au global ces fameuses idées
je vais vous dire je la connais pas donc
je vais la regarder parce que je vous me
la prenez mais l'intérêt de ces échanges
donc je vais je vais je vais la regarder
c'est vrai que au Canada je sais pas
s'il faut si c'est si c'est lié aussi
vous savez qu'il y a aussi une
immigration choisie voulue importante au
Canada pour des raisons démographiques
au Canada le Canada est une grande terre
d'immigration comme vous le savez
et je sais que et je sais que
il y a aussi peut-être le Canada aussi
dans ça dans sa politique de
l'immigration d'accélération
d'accélération
nécessité d'avoir aussi des logements
donc il faut que je regarde ça un peu
plus en détail mais je vais le regarder
vous m'avez vous avez attiré mon intérêt
mon attention sur cette question je vous
remercie
sur la quatrième question la quatrième
question c'était une question importante
aussi sur les médicaments et sur la
souveraineté sur les médicaments alors
c'est un c'est un point c'est un point
important sur cette question donc la
commission vient de proposer un nouveau
un nouveau paquet législatif pour
l'industrie de la santé donc il va dans
le sens que vous indiquez je vous invite
à en prendre connaissance si vous me
permettez vous savez aussi que certains
acteurs de demandent maintenant un
format acte comme on a fait un cheap Act
ou comme on a fait un Clinton Act alors
on est en train d'y réfléchir c'est
peut-être pertinent avec des des
investissements particuliers la
définition de quel type de de substrat
de composants de souches il faudrait
qu'on développe plus en Europe ou je
dirais référence aussi je l'ai véhicules
au début notamment sur certains
composants antibiotiques
[Musique]
référence de doliprane et autres mais
donc il faut pouvoir avoir
peut-être plus de maîtrise donc on est
en train de réfléchir à cette question
c'est encore un peu tôt mais mais cette
question est sur la table vous savez
également qu'on a en préparation un pied
donc un projet d'intérieur Européen
Commun donc sur la santé pour augmenter
nos capacités donc dans des domaines
spécifiques qui va être soutenu donc là
encore une fois par de l'argent public
donc sur ces questions donc voilà on est
on est on est sur cette la grande
question c'est savoir est-ce qu'on va
aller jusqu'à proposer un format comme
on l'a fait c'est en discussion
aujourd'hui au sein des services de la
Commission je peux pas m'avancer
l'avantage là-dessus mais la question
est bien sur la table alors j'avais
ensuite une cinquième question qui était
sur la juste contribution des réseaux
télécom alors on a lancé une très large
consultation sur cette question alors
j'ai souhaité qu'elle soit plus large
alors j'ai bien conscience du problème
je connais un petit peu le sujet comme
vous le savez donc j'ai bien conscience
du problème tel que vous l'avez posé
mais il nous a semblé important de le
poser y compris pour le traité dans une
dans une acceptation beaucoup plus large
et je vais vous dire comment la poser
puisqu'on a procédé à une très large
consultation vous êtes sans doute au
courant donc pour précisément comment on
fait systématiquement donc avant de
prendre la décision de proposer donc au
col législateur un texte qui pourrait
aller donc dans le sens que vous
indiquez la question c'est la suivante
c'est celle qu'on l'a posé on a
aujourd'hui des objectifs on appelle ça
la décennie numérique donc qui ont été
voulu par nos collégicateurs
c'est-à-dire l'ambition numérique du
continent européen à l'horizon 2030
connectivité pour tous accélère
largement etc
et donc derrière mais aussi beaucoup
plus de déploiement donc de services par
la 5G notamment et de services
industriels aussi avec l'émergence d'un
nombre très un volume très important de
donner industrielles qui va falloir
traiter c'est le Data acte en
particulier et puis le développement de
la 6G enfin tout ce qui est génération
et puis la notion de réseau virtuel et
puis la notion d'intégration dans les
réseaux de supercalculateurs de Edge
comme on dit pour pouvoir avoir des
capacités de traitement de données et de
stockage de données absolument massives
donc au plus près des utilisateurs donc
au fond un changement radical d'un
moment où le réseau ne vient que voler
véhiculer des flux au moment où on va
avoir des réseaux qui vont devoir se
dimensionner par rapport aux usages et
avec des capacités qui seront tellement
ou des des volumes sont tellement lourds
que pour beaucoup d'entre eux ils vont
être résidents par rapport je prends
l'exemple un hôpital il a besoin de
donner de donner de santé et c'est pas
la peine de lire véhicule et tous les
tous les jours du matin au soir dans un
sens ou dans un autre dans un Cloud il
va voir les avoir localisés un
constructeur automobile il va avoir des
données qui reviennent tous les jours de
l'usage c'est pas la peine de les mettre
à 10000 km il va falloir les localiser
au plus près de ceux qui ont fait des
services donc c'est c'est cette nouvelle
configuration des réseaux nécessaires
compris satellitaire parenthèse
que on a sur laquelle on a voulu se
poser et dans cette perspective qui est
pas uniquement dans la vision actuelle
où la régulation par parenthèse elle
date encore du moment où finalement il
fallait forcer les opérateurs
historiques à ouvrir leurs réseaux qui
étaient à l'époque des réseaux de cuivre
il y a pratiquement plus maintenant de
résoudre la régulation elle date de ça
de cette période là
on a remplacé ça évidemment par du haut
débit par de la fibre par du
satellitaire mais il faut aller plus
loin et essayer de bien avoir en
perspective de quel réseau on parle de
câlins-frastructure on parle en Europe
pour pouvoir permettre d'avoir
l'ambition numérique qui est la nôtre
donc ça c'est la consultation qui est en
cours et derrière chiffrer évidemment
tout ça et puis derrière parler des
contributions parce qu'il y a des
contributions publiques parce qu'elle
est contributions privées comment
rémunère ses investissements ils vont
être considérable aussi en amont pour
pouvoir le faire et dans cette question
évidemment la question de qui participe
en particulier les plateformes qui sont
les grands utilisateurs mais on a voulu
donc avoir cette vision globale plutôt
que d'avoir de traiter le problème je
dirais dans les réseaux de l'Ancien
Monde qui vous permettez qui sont encore
ceux et où il y a effectivement ce
problème et cette congestion bien bien
souvent en l'approchant dans cette
dynamique pour pouvoir présenter donc là
on est en train de maintenant on vient
de finir la consultation on va la
dépouiller dans l'été on va en faire
résultats donc je serai demain du reste
à Luxembourg pour commencer à parler de
tout ça avec le réseau avec le Conseil
des ministres Telecoms donc on va en
parler demain à Luxembourg donc on vient
la consultation vient d'être terminée là
donc maintenant il faut la dépouiller et
donc on va ensuite commencer à rendre
public donc les premières pistes donc
euh au cours du second semestre de
l'année prochaine puis après ça voir des
pistes de proposition pour aller dans le
sens que vous évoquez mais vous voyez
qu'on a voulu élargir parce que le sujet
est que vous évoquez est important mais
le sujet tel qu'on
a posé sur la table et je crois
essentiel pour notre autonomie et pour
notre futur au niveau européen je le
redis il va falloir les investissements
considérable aussi en matière
d'infrastructure numérique y compris les
câbles y compris la sécurité des câbles
sous-marins et à toutes ces questions de
sécurité complexes cybersécurité qui
interviennent dans la dans la
constitution des réseaux donc il est
temps peut-être de se poser la question
de voir si notre régulation aujourd'hui
du secteur répond à ces défis c'est donc
tout l'enjeu qu'on a posé
c'est exactement et ça vous l'avez
compris évidemment puisque derrière tous
ceux qui contribuent il faut qu'un
modèle ou tous ceux qui contribuent y
participent
une bonne question
j'avais une sixième question qui
concerne le protectionnisme alors les
protectionnisme et
donc dans l'environnement géopolitique
alors la question qui avait été posée
était
clairement sur
les évolutions donc géopolitique c'est
vrai qu'on commence à voir de plus en
plus des blocs se constitués je parlais
tout à l'heure dans l'évolution de la
géopolitique des chaînes de valeurs avec
des blocs qui faut bien le dire sont de
plus en plus centré ça veut pas dire du
tout qu'on est à la fin de la
mondialisation c'est pas du tout ce que
je dis ça veut dire qu'il y a une
nouvelle
géopolitique des rapports de force
continentaux qui est en train de
s'écrire dans lesquelles il faut que
l'Europe s'inscrive pleinement par
rapport à ce qu'elle représente et par
rapport à son à son poids donc
dans cette question et je peux vous
permettre d'y répondre on a
effectivement répondu avec le netzadia
c'est une réponse pour pouvoir apporter
une réponse à nos entreprises et vous me
posez la question du nucléaire et du
fait que le nucléaire alors le nucléaire
je le dis ça permet de le dire merci de
me poser la question
il y a donc le texte et puis il y a une
annexe dans le texte le nucléaire figure
clairement et j'y veillé et donc le net
Zia on pourra financer notamment des
réacteurs de 3e génération de 4e
génération les fiouls donc sa figure de
façon explicite et puis il y avait une
annexe des domaines qui sont considérés
comme le terme était malheureux donc
j'espère que les cholesters vont le
changer parce que le terme disait donc
des technologies stratégiques qui vont
donc bénéficier d'une accélération
d'autorisation de permis et pourquoi le
nucléaire n'avait pas été mis dedans
parce que dans le nucléaire il y aura
pas d'accélération de permis parce que
les contraintes sont tellement fortes
que évidemment donc on s'est dit ah bah
tiens ça c'est stratégie que ça allait
pas non c'était uniquement les les
composants
qui sont nécessaires à la transition
donc plus verte de notre énergie qui
vont pouvoir bénéficier pour faire une
usine par exemple de pales de
d'éolienne au lieu au lieu d'attendre 18
mois on pourra attendre 9 mois pour
faire une usine de l'électrolyseur plus
d'un 33 ans on pourra on pourra la faire
en 18 mois mais pour faire le nucléaire
il faudra toujours avoir le même type de
contraintes donc non le nucléaire il
figure
je peux vous dire que je me suis battu
pour ça mais c'est peut-être qu'il faut
changer le mot stratégique pour éviter
qu'il y a justement cette mauvaise
compréhension par rapport à l'objectif
ce qui est l'objectif sur lequel je me
suis moi-même beaucoup battu et je
rappelle que il y a plus de 15 pays ça
se paye maintenant qui sont tous donc
c'est-à-dire la majorité des États
membres comme je le rappelle le mix
énergétique par le traité est à la main
exclusive donc du choix des États
membres et là il y en a il y en a plus
de la moitié aujourd'hui qui ont marqué
le soutien à l'initiative qui avait été
lancé par Agnès panière une haché
d'avoir les États membres qui
soutiennent le nucléaire et voilà c'est
leur droit donc on peut pas accepter que
certains disent que ils sont
minoritaires et que dans la minorité
doit s'imposer à autres c'est le traité
le respect du traité malheureusement les
députés qui m'a peut-être question n'est
plus là mais il faut toujours toujours
en matière communautaire regarder et
revenir au traité et les traiter sont
excessivement clairs là-dessus voilà on
porte pas de jugement si ce que les
voisins font et bien pas mal on respecte
les traités le dernier la dernière
question donc le rôle numérique c'est
pas une réponse directe évidemment
mais mais je voudrais juste te dire que
les sanctions
puisque il s'agit au fond les sanctions
c'est évidemment
si à la main du conseil c'est les États
membres
qui les décide comme vous le savez donc
là dessus c'est donc les États membres
qui vont décider ou non donc d'avoir un
jeu de sanction et comme vous le savez
des questions des discussions assez
nourri on va dire au conseil en ce
moment et en particulier donc sur les
sanctions imposées à la Russie en
réaction à la guerre qui a déclenché les
bien Poutine mais c'est la main des
c'est vraiment à la main à la main du du
conseil donc je veux pas là répondre à
sa place et je peux faire très attention
il en à moins que la question vous
soulevez est une question qui est
légitime elle est largement débattue
et et et je dirais que
elle est revue systématiquement en
permanence porté par le Haut
représentant donc
j'espère que les questions vous soulevez
seront débattus en tout cas je m'en
ferai les cours mais je ne peux faire je
ne peux jouer que ce rôle là et je veux
pas s'en sortir de de ma condition je
vous parlais de l'euro numérique parce
que ça c'est plus dans les dans de
conditions et je pense c'est un jeu
c'est un rôle extrêmement important
quand je vois en particulier il faut
appeler un chat le rôle que je joue par
exemple Visa et MasterCard
avec derrière tout ce que ça veut dire
sur les interdictions dans nos simples
interactions y compris
personnellement donc on est même déjà
des usagers donc potentiellement
susceptibles d'être les utilisateurs
sans savoir même et donc potentiellement
acteur ou victime des sanctions sans le
savoir donc il faut que tous ces choses
là soient clairement ça va se chantier
voilà je j'ai essayé de couvrir
l'ensemble des réponses je veux juste
comment inviter je crois à conclure
Messieurs les Présidents vous remercier
de cet échange qui est extrêmement
instructif pour moi vous dire que
dans dans mon rôle de commissaire au
marché intérieur vous avez vous le savez
il a été très largement élargi et je
crois que c'était la volonté du
Président de la République lorsqu'il en
a discuté avant même que je n'arrivais
moi-même à la commission donc
parce que c'est la première fois je
reviens un commissaire couvre un champ
aussi large et des sa volonté c'était
pas ce que j'ai demandé c'est puisque
j'ai je dirais
trouver cette situation lorsque je suis
arrivé dans les conditions que que non
c'est un mot que je n'utiliserai pas
mais
dans les conditions que vous savez c'est
donc le marché intérieur c'est le
numérique dans son ensemble c'est
l'espace c'est la défense et donc ça me
permet d'avoir vraiment je crois en main
alors je spectre des outils qui sont
donc à ma disposition au sein de la
commission pour augmenter dans tous ces
secteurs donc notre autonomie notre
autonomie stratégique tel que je vous
l'ai dit je le redis autonomie
stratégique souveraineté c'est pas le
protectionnisme
on est absolument inaïf nibéa on sait
très bien que on va continuer à coopérer
avec les autres on sait très bien qu'on
va continuer à interagir avec les autres
en particulier avec la Chine on le sait
mais on sait aussi que pour se faire il
faut qu'on soit confiant et conscient de
nous forces
l'Europe a des forces l'Europe c'est pas
une faiblesse pendant des décennies
les ennemis de l'Europe et donc nos
ennemis
dans cessé de vouloir démontrer que
l'Europe était faible en essayant de
jouer les uns contre les autres je me
souviens très bien de ce qui a fait en
particulier la Russie depuis des
décennies la lumière Poutine n'aime pas
le projet européen il a cessé de le
laisser de diviser les uns et les autres
parce qu'ils avaient peur d'avoir une
robe qu'est-ce qu'elle est mais c'est
notre destin à nous on demande rien la
personne on est ce qu'on est et c'est
parce qu'on est ce qu'on est que on est
on est on est plus fort donc mon rôle à
moi c'est aussi de faire prendre
conscience à nous européens aux
industriels que nous sommes plus
puissants et plus fort ensemble
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que le
travail ensemble c'est moins de barrière
dans le marché intérieur c'est plus de
fluidité c'est faire en sorte que les
États membres respectent aussi les uns
et les autres les obligations qui sont
les leurs en matière de marché intérieur
et de libre et circulation des produits
et des services je le rappelle et c'est
pas comme ça que on pourra clairement
continuer à augmenter notre capacité de
commercer de dialoguer je dirais en
égaux avec les autres grandes puissances
de la planète et je pense en particulier
et à la Chine et aux États-Unis et mon
discours il est très ferme sur ces
questions il est très clair on est ce
qu'on est et on n'est pas là pour être
soumis à je ne sais qui ouais je ne sais
quoi en revanche quand il y a une guerre
qui est décidée sur notre continent et
qui était lancé
et que derrière le pays qui a lancé
cette guerre
veut entraîner d'autres dans cette
guerre utilisent les dépendances qu'il a
pu créer par le passé peut-être aussi
par une excès de naïveté je pense en
particulier aux dépenses du au gaz comme
des armes là oui notre responsabilité
c'est de nous découpler parce qu'on sait
que hélas pendant ce qui est là c'est
parce que la Russie est un grand pays
mais pendant sans doute des années
contenu de ce qu'on voit et de ce qui se
passe et de ce qui est fait on aura du
mal évidemment à commercer avec la
Russie
en tout cas dans le contexte qui a été
voulu par Vladimir Poutine donc là c'est
du découplage ni naïveté ni soumission
mais la compréhension de ce que veut
dire au 21e siècle que d'être un grand
continent car nous sommes en Europe un
grand continent merci merci beaucoup
Monsieur le Commissaire pour votre temps
et la qualité de vos réponses merci
monsieur le Président pour cette
coprésidence merci chers collègue pour
votre présence prochaine réunion de la
commission des affaires économiques
mercredi prochain 9h30 on examinera la
PPL relative au pluie de la communauté
de communes du Bas-Chablais et puis le
mercredi prochain à 17h nous aurons Marc
féno que nous auditionnerons en
commission des affaires économiques
merci beaucoup chers collègues